monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames messieurs les ministres
mesdames messieurs
heureux nous retrouver pour cette
conférence de presse dédiée à la
présidence française du conseil européen
qui commencera au 1er janvier prochain
et qui est un moment historique en ce
qu'il est rare à lui seul puisque dans
l'europe à 27 la france n'exerce en
effet cette présidence qu'une fois tous
les 13 ans tous les 13 ans elle a cette
responsabilité
de porter des ambitions pour l'europe
tout en nous inscrivons pleinement dans
le collectif européen et c'est tout à la
fois un rôle qui consiste
à pousser évidemment nos priorités nos
ambitions notre propre agenda mais
également à être les dépositaires une
forme d'harmonie est donc d'accord
européen qui doivent émerger durant
c'est simon hix et donc à partir du 1er
janvier 2020 et buzz nous aurons à vivre
ce temps dans un moment particulier que
je veux qualifier ici avant une autre et
lyon dans le fond de cette présidence
celui d'abord d'une crise sanitaire qui
se poursuit qui nous a durement frappé
et près de deux ans celui évidemment du
bouleversement climatique
la révolution numérique
d'inégalités mondiale croissante
d'enjeux migratoire exacerbée par les
manipulations de certains état de
tentatives de déstabilisation de nos
démocraties et de montée de tension
jusque dans notre voisinage le plus
direct
et donc face à toutes ces crises qui
percute l'europe nombreux sont ceux qui
voudraient qu'ils ne s'en remettre aux
seules nations
ces nations sont notre force notre
fierté mais l'unité européenne et leur
complément indispensable
et ce moment exige de nous à cet égard
plus d'efficacité plus d'affirmations
plus d'autonomie plus d'indépendance et
il dit je crois avant toute chose le
besoin de nous unir nous européens c'est
ce que nous avons cherché à traduire la
fois dans le le contenu même parce que
cette présidence portera mais également
à travers
l'emblème et les quelques éléments
symboliques qui vont caractériser cette
présidence et je vais peut-être tout de
suite avant de rentrer sur le le fond de
notre programme demandé au secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes qui
auprès du ministre de l'europe des
affaires européennes a conduit ces
travaux de nous présenter tout à la fois
cet emblème mais également la nouvelle
pièce je salue ici la présence notre
graveur et la monnaie
ici présentes qui est au travers de son
directeur général monsieur sarthe ont
travaillé sur ce sujet depuis de longs
mois et également de présenter la carte
de ces travaux à travers
le pays
dans la république nous allons vivre en
effet un moment très important pour
notre pays je crois pour toute l'union
européenne ce sont bien sûr les
chantiers politiques tes priorités
législatives en inde ambitieux que vous
allez présenter dans quelques instants
français mais ce sont aussi des symboles
une identité des messages que nous
portons à travers un certain nombre
d'exemples très concrets et je vous
propose de découvrir sans plus attendre
l'emblème que nous avons retenu pour la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne
cet emblème que nous avons choisie pour
six mois représente initiale de l'uni
habillés des couleurs de la france des
étoiles non européenne nous y tenons
unis une flèche porte un message
d'ambition ou à venir qui consiste à
aller de l'avant face aux tentations du
repli pourquoi du renoncement ce modèle
de l'europe nous le défendons sous votre
autorité monsieur prendre la république
de cuillé d'ambition war venir qui
consiste à aller de l'avant face aux
tentations du repli ou parfois du
renoncement
ce modèle de l'europe nous le défendons
sous votre autorité monsieur tron la
république depuis quatre ans pour une
europe plus souveraine plus unie plus
démocratique nous avons essayé de le
résumer de résumer les priorités que
vous allez présenter aussi dans une
devise je vous propose immédiatement
deux voire trois mots qui incarne cette
ambition européenne
la relance la puissance et
l'appartenance
la relance parce que nous sommes encore
dans un moment de crise et nous
construisons au niveau européen une
réponse économique le réarmement
économique de l'europe est encore plus
que jamais nécessaire nous essaierons le
faire avancer la puissance parce qu'elle
est la condition du modèle européen que
nous devons préserver et promouvoir dans
le monde puis l'appartenance car aucun
projet politique ne saurait durer sans
un sentiment collectif de participer à
une aventure importante ce sont des
valeurs partager une culture que nous
avons en commun une histoire qui nous
relient les plaies pour l'avenir
nous avons aussi souhaité vous avez
saluer monsieur prendre la république le
directeur général de la monnaie de paris
et le graveur général que je salue à mon
tour nous avons souhaité un objet très
simple si je puis dire ainsi sonnant et
trébuchant pour incarner cette
présidence je vous propose de découvrir
une nouvelle pièce de deux euros
je crois que normalement chacun la
normale ont chacun on a un exemple est
frappé monsieur le directeur général
cette pièce de deux euros est important
d'abord parce que c'est la première fois
depuis l'entrée en fonction dans les
portefeuilles des français des européens
des pièces en euros qu'en france nous
changeons le dessin de cette pièce bien
sûr cela consiste à marquer
l'anniversaire de la monnaie unique 2022
seront aussi les 20 ans de l'euro les
français comme les européens y sont
attachés ils sont très attachés même
plus que jamais ils soutiennent la
monnaie unique en font un élément de
stabilité de protection d'attractivité
de nos économies qui nous a protégés
aussi pendant la crise sur ce symbole
qui a été dessiné par joachim gimenez le
graveur général de la monnaie de paris
je crois que nous voyons une continuité
avec pièces que nous avons mais aussi
une modernisation écologique notamment
les devises la devise de la république
qui se retrouve le chêne et l'olivier la
force et la sagesse
jacinto ciel c'est un symbole qui ne
sera pas simplement commémoratif ce sera
une vraie pièce qui est le 1er janvier
2022 sera en circulation qui est frappée
à pessac au coeur de la gironde comme
les premiers rôles ont été depuis 24 ans
et qui sera utilisable par chacun
d'entre nous comme un signe de cette
europe que nous avons auprès de nous
dans notre quotidien
et puis cette europe monsieur le
président vous avez voulu qu'elle soit
incarnée qu'elle souhaite aussi
enracinée dans toute la france dans les
territoires de l'hexagone et des
outre-mer et nous aurons pendant cette
présidence française semestre de
présidence française dans toutes les
régions de france voyons ici plus de
vingt réunions ministérielles qui seront
accueillis dans tous les domaines dans
toutes les régions l'occasion de montrer
cette europe au plus près de valoriser
aussi notre patrimoine notre culture sur
tous les thèmes au cours des semaines
qui viennent vous préciserez aussi le
croit monsieur le président un certain
nombre d'événements que vous présiderez
à votre niveau une europe des symboles
de l'identité de la proximité c'est ce
que nous avons recherché un carnet à
travers ces éléments je veux saluer à
cette occasion monsieur présente toutes
les équipes qui partout au sein de
l'état ont déjà fait un travail
exceptionnel pour préparer ce moment qui
est une responsabilité
un honneur important pour notre pays je
vous remercie merci beaucoup merci pour
pour cela à nouveau merci à la monnaie
de paris à l'ensemble des équipes qui
ont oeuvré pendant des mois et je vais
montrer remercier vraiment le ministre
de l'europe des affaires étrangères et
secrétaire d'état ainsi que l'ensemble
des équipes de diplomates qui ont oeuvré
à leur côté pour préparer cette
présidence
le secrétariat général son secrétaire
général qui depuis plusieurs mois nous
préparer évidemment l'ensemble des
diplomates au quai d'orsay notre
représentation permanente à bruxelles et
ses équipes le secrétariat général aux
affaires européennes auprès du premier
ministre car cette tâche vous le voyez
l'avait vu un instant occupe aussi
beaucoup de politiques publiques
françaises est évidemment les
différentes équipes diplomatiques aussi
à matignon et à l'elysée et l'ensemble
des ministres je remercie les ministres
ici présents aujourd'hui mais c'est un
travail profondément interministériel
qui a occupé le gouvernement pendant
plusieurs mois et qui est aussi le fruit
d'un travail intense du gouvernement
depuis plusieurs mois pour préparer
cette présidence alors s'il fallait
résumer en une phrase
l'objectif de cette présidence qui
s'étendra du 1er janvier au 30 juin je
dirais que nous devons passer d'une
europe de coopération à l'intérieur de
nos frontières à une europe puissante
dans le monde pleinement souveraine
libre de ses choix et maître de son
destin et c'est ça l'objectif que nous
devons poursuivre pour la première fois
en effet depuis près d'un demi-siècle
des questions existentielles nous sont
posées sur le plan climatique sur le
plan technologique
sur le plan géopolitique qui impose et
c'est ce que nous préparons déjà vous
savez depuis plusieurs années de
profondément transformé notre
organisation de nous doter d'une
ambition nouvelle
j'avais eu l'occasion de présenter cet
agenda dès l'automne 2010 est à la
sorbonne et nous avons déjà parachever
beaucoup des objectifs qui avaient été
alors annoncée
mais ce travail aujourd'hui est rendu
encore plus indispensable par le
contexte que j'évoquais à l'instant
alors ses priorités et la construction
au fond de cette souveraineté européenne
est ce modèle européen nous avons
travaillé toutes ces dernières semaines
avec les différents états membres avec
le président du conseil avec lequel
j'étais il y à quelques instants la
présidente de la commission avec
lesquels je l'échangé lundi évidemment
le président du parlement européen qui
était avec le premier ministre ministres
affaires étrangères il ya quelques
instants comme avec les groupes
parlementaires et j'étais à leurs côtés
le 2 décembre dernier à strasbourg pour
un longue échanges pour préparer cette
présidence j'exposerai l'ensemble de ses
priorités devant le parlement européen
le 19 janvier à strasbourg au fond le
mois de janvier sera marquée par une
série d' échanges avec le président du
conseil avec la commission et l'ensemble
du collège des commissaires européens en
france donc début janvier puis un
échange comme il se doit avec le
parlement européen le 19 janvier à
strasbourg
le premier axe de cette présidence c'est
cette europe plus souveraine
l'europe souveraine c'est d'abord c'est
pour moi le premier aspect une europe
capable de maîtriser ses frontières
ces dernières semaines où l'ont encore
montré à travers la crise que nous avons
vécue à la frontière orientera orientale
de l'europe dès la fin de l'été à la
frontière lituanienne et layton puis à
la frontière polonaise
protéger nos frontières est une
condition indispensable à la fois pour
assurer la sécurité des européens pour
relever le défi migratoire et éviter les
drames que nous avons vécu les
situations de fortes tensions que nous
avons vécu les guerres hybride auxquels
nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à la
frontière avec la biélorussie mais
également les drames humains ensuite qui
en sont les conséquences directes à
travers ces trafics qui sont organisées
comme ce que nous avons vécu dans la
manche il y a quelques semaines à vers
le drame que nous connaissons tous et
pour éviter que le droit d'asile qui a
été inventé sur le continent européen et
qui est notre honneur ne puisse être
dévoyé nous devons absolument retrouver
une europe qui sache protéger ses
frontières et retrouve sur la question
migratoire une organisation politique
qui nous met en situation de défendre
ses valeurs c'est pourquoi nous nous
initierons sous cette présidence une
réforme de l'espace schengen autour de
deux priorités
la première ce sera la mise en place
d'un pilotage politique de schengen
comme nous l'avons fait pour
la zone euro nous avons mis en place une
organisation politique de celle ci avec
des réunions régulières au niveau des
ministres des finances
nous souhaitons installer une
organisation et un pilotage politique de
cet espace schengen à travers des
réunions régulières des ministres en
charge de ces questions
c'est en effet de la crédibilité
européenne et en particulier de celles
et ceux qui se sont engagés dans cette
coopération renforcée que schengen de
pouvoir avoir des réunions régulières de
prendre des décisions politiques de
pouvoir renforcer les contrôles aux
frontières et d'avoir une politique
cohérente de maîtrise
de nos frontières extérieures c'est la
condition préalable à la libre
circulation au sein de schengen ceci
vient s'appuyer sur une réforme que nous
sommes en train de parachever par le
dialogue et les travaux avec la
commission européenne et qui donnera
lieu à des textes permettant d'améliorer
le fonctionnement interne de cet espace
deuxièmement
souhaitons porter la création d'un
mécanisme de soutien d'urgence aux
frontières en cas de crise quand un état
membre doit soudainement faire face à
une crise qui exigent de renforcer le
contrôle aux frontières extérieures de
notre union comme nous l'avons vécue
comme une fois récemment il doit pouvoir
compter sur l'appui de frontex agence
commune dont c'est la vocation mais
également le renfort solidaire des états
membres en policiers gendarmes comme en
matériel là encore nous avons eu
l'occasion de le faire il y a plusieurs
semaines
lorsque
justement certains nos partenaires ont
appelé au secours mais les réactions
sont souvent trop tardive les mécanismes
met en place je dirais à chaque fois de
manière spécifique il nous faut créer
véritablement ce mécanisme de soutien
intergouvernementale troisièmement sur
ce sujet de la protection de nos
frontières nous souhaitons également
sous présidence française faire enfin
avancer ce qu'on appelle le paquet
migratoire européen c'est-à-dire la
meilleure aussi organisation de notre
europe en termes de gestion des
migrations avec une volonté qui est
toujours la même
travailler avec les pays d'origine et
les pays de transit pour lutter contre
les trafics éviter ces flux protéger nos
frontières extérieures
harmoniser nos règles en particulier en
matière d'asile
d'accompagnement des réfugiés ou des
migrants qui sont sur notre sol et
harmonisation aussi d'une gestion de ce
qu'on appelle les flux secondaire c'est
à dire de la circulation des femmes et
des hommes qui une fois arrivé sur le
sol européen
doivent être beaucoup mieux à la fois
suivies accompagnées avec des procédures
plus simples plus harmonisée au niveau
européen pour éviter des jeux non
coopératifs entre les états membres que
nous voyons que plusieurs années
ce texte est aujourd'hui essentiel et
nous souhaitons pouvoir dans le semestre
prochain le faire avancer au delà de la
protection des frontières extérieures
que j'évoquais à l'instant le deuxième
élément clé d'une europe plus souveraine
c'est évidemment d'avancé sur notre
politique de défense
vous le savez là aussi depuis 2010 est
nous avons beaucoup porter l'ambition
d'une défense européenne
avec des avancées considérables
un fonds européen de défense
l'initiative open d'intervention des
coopérations là encore une fois
structuré et plusieurs programme commun
franco-allemand ensuite ouvert à
d'autres états membres en matière
d'armement
qu'il s'agisse de l'armement qui sont
dédiés à notre armée de l'air où notre
armée de terre
sur le fondement des initiatives prises
depuis quatre ans il nous faut
aujourd'hui entré dans une phase plus
opérationnelle
et finir pour nous européens nos
intérêts communs et une stratégie
partagée dans un monde de menacer de
risque cette présidence sera à cet égard
un moment de définition de ce que nous
avons appelé la boussole stratégiques
c'est-à-dire un livre blanc européen de
défense et de sécurité
qui à la fois présentera l'état des
menaces et fixera nos choix collectifs
nos orientations nos ambitions cette
boussole stratégique a été lancée sous
présidence allemande est elle aboutira
manière concrète sous présidence
française lors du conseil européen du
mois de mars nous aurons d'ailleurs des
discussions lors du conseil de descendre
puis lors du sommet que nous souhaitons
en france au mois de mars sur ce sujet
quelle est la vocation de cette de cette
stratégie d'abord de définir
véritablement
une souveraineté
stratégiques européennes ce concept qui
paraissait impensable là encore une fois
il ya quatre ans permet d'ancrer que
nous européens
que nous soyons d'ailleurs membres de
l'otan ou pas parce que je dois perdre
plusieurs états membres ne de l'union
européenne ne sont pas membres de l'otan
mais pour tous ceux qui sont membres de
l'otan ils réaffirment leur adhésion à
cette organisation qui a montré son
utilité et son efficacité mais nous
avons des menaces communes et des
objectifs communs et donc nous allons
ainsi définir et porter ensemble une
analyse commune de ces menaces portées
des ambitions nouvelles en matière
d'industrie de défense acte est aussi
d'exercices conjoints de définir nos
partenariat conjoint et au fond de
définir également pour les européens
notre organisation commune sur les
nouveaux espaces de conflits qualité que
sont l'espace maritime
le spatial et le cyber
le conseil européen du mois de mars
permettra d' acte et cette boussole qui
a fait l'objet d'un très gros travail de
la part des différents états membres de
la commission et du rock du haut
représentant et de préparer ainsi des
position commune en vue du sommet de jeu
juin à madrid de l'otan elle permettra
aussi de manière très concrète de lancer
pour la première fois des exercices
communs
renforcement de l'industrie de défense
européen le troisième acte de cette
europe souveraine c'est la stabilité et
la prospérité de notre voisinage il n'y
a pas d'europe souveraine si nous ne
décidons pas en européens d'avoir notre
propre stratégie notre propre agenda
pour ce qui est notre voisinage sans
être exhaustif je veux ici ici citer
deux espaces géographiques qui donneront
lieu à des initiatives sous présidence
française structurantes
depuis le début de mon mandat j'ai fait
de la relation avec l'afrique une
priorité et je crois en effet
profondément que le lien entre nos deux
continents qui bordent les deux rives de
la méditerranée et le grand projet
police politique et géopolitique des
décennies à venir la relation entre
l'afrique et l'europe sera structurantes
à tous égards
pour la paix autour de la méditerranée
mais aussi pour la paix la prospérité et
de l'europe et de l'afrique
c'est notre intérêt commun la france a
lancé plusieurs initiatives à cet égard
nous avons essayé de bâtir depuis quatre
ans forme d'aggiornamento de notre
politique africaine et de notre
stratégie
mais nous devons le faire en europe et
un en bâtissant un avenir à la jeunesse
africaine pour réduire les inégalités
lutter contre les trafics qui exploitent
la misère et les passeurs qui ont fait
de la méditerranée un cimetière honteux
et donc
nous organiserons à cet égard en lien
très étroit avec
le président michel la présidente
fondèrent la hyène et l'ensemble des
états membres un sommet entre l'union
africaine et l'union européenne au mois
de février qui se tiendra à bruxelles et
qui réunira les dirigeants des pays et
des institutions de l'union africaine et
de l'union européenne
l'objectif de ce sommet est de refonder
en profondeur la relation parce qu'elle
s'était elle-même il faut bien le dire à
travers ces instruments
bureaucratisé est un peu fatiguée elle
doit s'appuyer sur plusieurs axes que
nous avons préparé ces derniers mois
d'abord refonder un new deal économique
et financier avec l'afrique c'est ce que
nous avons préparé lors du sommet du 18
mai dernier qui s'est tenue si vous en
souvenez à paris sur le financement des
économies africaines c'est celui qui
nous avait permet de déclencher la réole
up la réallocation des droits de tirage
spéciaux du fonds monétaire
international vers les pays africains et
qui nous a permis d'acter ce mécanisme
lors du dernier g20 à rome nous devons
nous européens
aller au bout de cette solidarité à
l'égard des africains qui consiste
simplement à regarder les chiffres qui
sont donnés par la banque mondiale et le
fmi le fait qu entre 2020 et 2025
il y à 300 milliards d'euros de besoins
de financement pour les économies
africaines car ils ont les conséquences
économiques et financières de lakovic 19
agirait est une véritable explosion
démographique embrasser et donc à cet
égard l'europe doit dans les instances
internationales porter une stratégie
commune avec l'afrique pour permettre
cette solidarité est elle-même
réactualiser ses mécanismes
d'investissement solidaire à l'égard du
continent africain ensuite c'est de
déployer un agenda en matière
d'éducation de santé et de climat à la
hauteur des enjeux de l'afrique sur ses
trois grands axes le continent africain
à des défis qui sont encore plus
importants que les nôtres sur les deux
questions nous avons relancé en lien
avec le président macky sall il ya
maintenant près de quatre ans
un partenariat commun dans le cadre
justement du partenariat mondial pour
l'éducation nous allons poursuivre l'
european ise avec un vrai projet de
développer plus avant l'éducation des
jeunes filles partout en afrique mais
également la formation des enseignants
comme le développement des structures
d'éducation sur la santé nous l'europe a
été pionnière en proposant au g20 le
mécanisme dit acta et en ayant cette
solidarité à travers kovacs mais aussi
le transfert de technologie et la
production vers l'afrique c'est ce que
nous allons développer sous présidence
justement française en ayant un
véritable agenda
sanitaire qui consiste à déployer
beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup plus fort
des structures de production de vaccins
et de production justement de systèmes
de santé primaires et puis sur le climat
nous devons accompagner dans sa
transition énergétique et climatique le
continent africain nous ne pouvons pas
laisser les états africains sont
solution leurs défis sont encore plus
importants que les nôtres nous avons
commencé à structurer cet agenda commun
à travers des grandes initiatives
lancées en début d'année comme la grande
muraille verte qui permet de répondre à
la fois haut débit aux défis de la
biodiversité et du climat en afrique
mais là aussi à travers des financements
d'infrastructures et de solutions
énergétiques
nous allons structurer une initiative
forte dans le cadre de ce sommet
troisième grands axes de cette
coopération c'est la sécurité en effet
la france comme vous le savez est
particulièrement impliquée mais nous
souhaitons européaniser c'est ce que
nous faisons dans le cadre justement de
nos actions au sahel mais européaniser
ce partenariat et avoir véritablement un
partenariat de sécurité entre l'afrique
et l'europe ce qui est la demande des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement pour
faire face à la montée du terrorisme sur
leur continent et puis quatrième point
d'avoir un agenda sur les mobilités
choisies la lutte contre les passeurs la
lutte contre justement ce système de
misère qui s'est mise en place et
exploiter les situations plus difficiles
et plus difficile et permettre aussi
d'organiser l'émigration choisie
qu'elles soient scientifiques
culturelles académique au sein du
continent africain et entre l'afrique et
l'europe voilà les grands axes qui
seront qui structureront ce sommet de
refondation du 17 et 18 février
prochains c'est un véritable contrat de
paix de prospérité que nous souhaitons
mettre en place pour bâtir des
investissements dans les économies
africaines est justement construire
cette cet avenir commun cet agenda nous
l'avons construit avec les africains au
travers de réunions successives que j'ai
pu tenir ici à paris que le président
charles michel aussi à multiplient
encore ces derniers jours qu avec les
ministres nous avons construite au moins
de mai autour justement de ce sommet de
paris lors du forum de paris pour la
paix et que nous poursuivrons dans les
prochaine semaines notre voisinage
immédiat enfin ce sont aussi les balkans
occidentaux
nous organiserons au mois de juin une
conférence sur les balkans occidentaux
parce que plus qu'un voisinage les
balkans sont au coeur de l'europe il
suffit de regarder une carte il suffit
de regarder notre histoire
cette région est aujourd'hui traversé
par des nouvelles tensions
l'histoire y est de retour le tragique
parfois aussi et donc nous avons une
responsabilité aujourd'hui toute
particulière à l'égard des balkans
occidentaux
nous devons y mener une politique de
réengagement mais également
d'investissements pour favoriser
l'intégration économique de cette région
pour y développer les échanges humains
pour évoquer la question des minorités
qui parcourt toute cette région et pour
lutter aussi contre les interférences
contre les manipulations qui sont le
fait de puissants de plusieurs
puissances régionales qui cherche à
travers les balkans à déstabiliser
l'europe je crois que ce travail qui est
un travail et politiques et économiques
à l'égard des balkans occidentaux
est un véritable agenda de souveraineté
pour notre europe car on ne pourra pas
bâtir l'europe de plaider 50 prochaines
années si nous laissons les balkans
occidentaux dans la situation où ils
sont aujourd'hui et c'est donc clarifier
leurs perspectives européennes
réinvestir dans cette région et son
unité et
avoir véritablement une ambition commune
pour les décennies à venir voilà les
trois grands axes à mes yeux de ce
qu'est une europe plus souveraine sur
laquelle comme vous le voyez le prochain
semestre donnera lieu à des rendez vous
extrêmement important qui viennent
parfois parachever une ambition que nous
nous poussons depuis plusieurs années
mais qui vont aussi marqué des réponses
très pratique pour nos concitoyens d'un
plus grand contrôle d'une plus grande
maîtrise le deuxième grand axe de cette
présidence française de l'union
européenne
qui je crois d'ailleurs et c'est
dessiner progressivement pour notre pays
comme pour notre continent durant ces
derniers mois et durant cette cette
pandémie que nous avons tous q consiste
à bâtir un nouveau modèle européen de
croissance au fond il nous faut définir
ensemble ce que sera l'europe de 2030
et cette présidence française doit être
l'occasion d'imaginer un nouveau modèle
européen qui est un modèle de production
mais également de solidarité de
régulation en effet notre europe doit
être une europe où on puisse produire
créer de la richesse de la richesse est
à la pointe de l'innovation une europe
aussi qu'il doit défendre son modèle
social parce que nous n'avons pas les
mêmes choix collectifs que l'asie ou les
états unis d'amérique et une europe qui
doit être au coeur de l'agenda
climatique qui est aussi qui correspond
à nos valeurs à cet égard et je dirais
pour bâtir cette stratégie décennale
nous organiserons le 10 et 11 mars en
france un sommet exceptionnel des 27
chefs d'état et de gouvernement autour
de ce sujet majeur qui est au fond de
définir le nouveau modèle de croissance
européen nous aurons l'occasion d'en
détailler les contours plus précis mais
il repose
à meyzieu autour de quatre piliers que
je veux simplement ici esquissé premier
pilier c'est évidemment la capacité à
produire à avoir une réponse économique
adapté à la sortie de crise avec une
priorité
faire de l'europe un grand continent de
production d'innovation de création
d'emplois et nous devons partout en
europe avoir une obsession créer des
emplois et lutter contre le chômage et
le chômage de masse tout
particulièrement
cet agenda est indispensable en sortie
de crise parce que nous avons et nous
aurons à vivre les conséquences
économiques et sociales de cette
pandémie pour cela nous avons à bâtir ce
que nous avons commencé à préparer mais
ce sommet de mars permettra d'en
parachever le travail et la cohérence la
construction de filières industrielles
fortes et intégrée l'hydrogène les
batteries l'espace les semi conducteurs
le cloud la défense la santé
la culture et les industries culturelles
et créatives
dans tous ces domaines à haute intensité
technologique de création de valeur ou
d'emplois qui vont structurer le monde
de 2030 qui vont structurer la création
d'emploi la création de valeur ajoutée
ou la capacité à avoir de l'influencé
sur le monde de demain nous devons
garantir le positionnement de l'europe
notre capacité à avoir évidemment des
champions notre capacité à créer le
maximum d'emplois sur notre sol et notre
capacité à définir les standards de
demain et avoir donc notre indépendance
pour cela l'action au niveau d'un état
n'est pas la bonne échelle vous m'avez
plusieurs fois entendu dire cela mais
quand nous avons amené la compétition
par rapport aux chinois aux états unis
d'amérique quand parfois nous avons pris
du retard ce qui est le cas de certains
de ses grands sujets je pense au cloud
aux semi conducteurs par exemple où
l'europe de fait à d'ores et déjà des
dépendance technologique
si nous voulons le rattraper et parfois
prendre de l'avancé nous devons agir en
européens et nous devons penser en
européen nos investissements en matière
de compétences d'implantation
industrielle
d'innovation soit pour réindustrialiser
soit pour bâtir de nouvelles filières
innovantes et pour là aussi construire
de la véritable souveraineté
technologique en europe et donc d'ici le
mois de mars nous parachèveront et la
commission européenne un rôle tout
particulier une série de plans
d'investissement européen et d'alliances
industrielles nouvelles autour de ses
grands objectifs que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
ce modèle de croissance et
d'investissements supposera aussi des
règles budgétaires et financières
adaptées
permettant de donner la priorité aux
investissements nécessaires pour
accompagner les transitions en
particulier climatique et numérique
nous aurons pour cela besoin de
commencer à bâtir
un cadre budgétaire et financier
crédible simplifiée transparent capable
de contribuer à cette ambition d'une
europe plus forte plus juste et plus
durable et lors de ce sommet du 10 et 11
mars nous aurons ainsi une session de
réflexion stratégique que nous
organiserons pour les 27 états membres
autour de ce sujet qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que durant la pandémie
nous avons
mises entre parenthèses d'application de
nos règles budgétaires communes
nous devrons revenir à des règles
budgétaires qui seuls permettent la
convergence entre nos économies surtout
pour celles et ceux qui partagent une
monnaie commune mais nous ne pouvons pas
faire comme si rien ne s'était passé et
pour réussir justement le développement
de ces alliances de ces filières
industrielles fortes et d'innovation il
nous faut acter le besoin
d'investissements nouveaux ces
investissements nouveaux nous devons les
intégrer dans notre cadre budgétaire et
donc il nous faut une discussion
stratégique qui découlent de cela les
dires face à ce défi à la transition
climatique numérique sanitaire culturel
stratégique comment notre europe doit
justement prendre les bons
investissements au bon niveau et
repenser notre cadre budgétaire à cet
égard nous ne réussirons pas cette
transition nous ne les mèneront pas à
l'échelle de notre continent si nous en
revenons à un cadre budgétaire qui a été
créé au début des années 90 en même
temps il nous faudra aussi
relancer un travail commun sur le cadre
financier
car si la banque centrale européenne à
une réaction rapide totalement adapté au
moment de la crise nous avons aussi à
parachever une europe bancaire et une
europe des marchés de capitaux parce que
face à tous ces investissements il nous
faut aussi levé au maximum de l'argent
privé et orienter ses financements
privés vers nos priorités ceci suppose
d'aller plus loin dans l'intégration
d'une europe d'un vrai marché de
capitaux d'une europe financière enfin
intégrer c'est au coeur de cet agenda et
c'est un élément de cohérence
car nous ne réussirons en effet ces
transformations que si nous savons
réadapter le règle budgétaire et
financière deuxième pilier de ce nouveau
modèle européen de croissance c'est de
concilier développement économique et
ambitions climatiques et l'europe a une
opportunité c'est de devenir championne
en la matière parce que c'est un levier
de création d'emplois et de valeur pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain en devenant
le premier continent du monde à adopter
l'objectif de neutralité carbone nous
nous sommes fixé un cadre ambitieux je
le rappelle c'était en décembre de
l'année dernière les 27 se sont engagés
les premiers autour de cet objectif
atteindre cet objectif suppose non pas
de produire moins et de consommer moins
mais d'innover de transformer nos
politiques de mettre en place ces bonne
régulation et les bons investissements
pour économiser
l'énergie qu'on peut économiser en
continuant à innover et produits pour
électrifier tout ce qui peut l'être et
pour avoir une production d'électricité
la plus décarbonés possible
il nous faut donc inventer les solutions
de décarbonation de notre économie soit
compatible avec cet agenda de croissance
le 14 juillet dernier la commission
européenne a présenté un ensemble de
textes législatifs
traduisant concrètement notre ambition
de neutralité carbone pour 2050 et de
réduction de 55% de nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre d'ici 2030
le semestre de présidence française doit
faire avancer ses textes avec toujours
un objectif ne pas perdre une minute car
il s'agit d'une urgence absolue avoir le
bon niveau d'investissement et
d'innovation pour permettre de concilier
développement économique ambitions
climatiques et avoir le bon niveau
d'accompagnement des industries et des
ménages pour permettre constamment l'
équilibre entre ambition climatique et
justice sociale et enfin garder notre
compétitivité notre ambition climatiques
en particulier sous présidence française
l'un de nos objectifs sera la mise en
place du mécanisme d'ajustement carbone
aux frontières
cette fameuse taxe entre guillemets
carbone aux frontières de l'europe qui
permet justement
de conduire cette transition pour
l'ensemble de nos industries en
préservant notre compétitivité ça
consiste en quoi eh bien à corriger le
fait que nous allons demander des
efforts d investissement les accompagner
décarbonés notre industrie mais que nous
continuerons à importer parfois des
biens qui viennent de régions qui ne
font toujours pas le même effort eh bien
nous compenserons à nos frontières
le différentiel sans quoi nos
industriels à juste titre ne dirai que
nous créons en quelque sorte un biais de
compétitivité et que nous allons
simplement supprimer notre industrie à
défaut de la moderniser
concilier compétitivité ambitions
industrielles avec l'ambition climatique
c'est mettre en place ce mécanisme qui
est clé est que nous souhaitons
parachever sous présidence française
ensuite nous souhaitons avancer sur la
mise en cohérence de notre politique
commerciale et de notre politique
climatique et de biodiversité
ainsi la présidence française sera un
moment clé pour pousser ce qu'on appelle
les clauses miroir et avoir des
exigences environnementales et sociales
dans nos accords commerciaux c'est n'a
aussi une question d'équité les acteurs
économiques européens ne peuvent pas
être les victimes de leurs efforts pour
la planète et donc ces clauses miroir
c'est une mise en cohérence de notre
agenda commercial avec notre agenda
climatique et nous allons dès d'ailleurs
tout faire ce ne se fera pas à l'échelle
de la présidence française de l'union
européenne pour que dans le cadre de la
réforme de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce nous puissions intégrer cet
agenda
environnementale et sociale
enfin sur ce sur ce volet nous ferons
aussi avancer les négociations sur la
mise en place d'un instrument européen
de lutte contre la déforestation
importés qui visera à interdire
l'importation dans l'union européenne de
soja boeuf fils de pam bois cacao café
quand ils contribuent à la déforestation
en effet il nous faut re synchronisée
notre agenda de lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et notre agenda
de préservation de la biodiversité
les deux sont liés
nous l'avons montré en début d'année en
organisant ici même le wat planète
soumise pour la biodiversité qui a
permis de relancer cet agenda durant
l'année 2021 et la france a porté la
première un agenda de lutte contre la
déforestation importés qui est très
cohérent avec là aussi notre politique
climatique et notre politique agricole
lorsque nous nous battons pour un plan
protéines nous luttons contre la
déforestation importés par des
substances protéiques qui viennent de
zones qui produisent ces protéines
végétales grâce à de la déforestation
donc vous voyez la cohérence et l'esprit
de système de cet agenda mais nous
devons le porter au niveau européen pour
être collectivement efficace et ainsi
défendre au niveau européen l'excellence
de notre modèle agricole qui est un
modèle de haute qualité que nous
souhaitons continuer d'accompagner dans
sa transformation et là aussi dans la
préservation de la biodiversité
troisième élément de ce nouveau modèle
européen de croissance
c'est de faire de l'europe une puissance
du numérique
le numérique est en train de transformer
évidemment tous nos secteurs de
production est au coeur des innovations
mondiales et réussir à créer de la
croissance des nouveaux emplois dans
notre continent réussir aussi à à
défendre nos valeurs nos principes c'est
réussir à créer une europe du numérique
en tout cas à la parachever
d'abord c'est réussir continuer de faire
émerger des acteurs de plus en plus fort
des champions du numérique en soutenant
l'innovation et la croissance des
acteurs émergent dans ce domaine la
france mène un peu plus de quatre ans
une stratégie en la matière qui a montré
son efficacité à travers les résultats
que nous avons sur l'europe continentale
en termes de levée de fonds de création
de start up et de lever aujourd'hui des
tickets les plus importants nous
souhaitons européaniser cette stratégie
et réussir à avoir justement des fonds
européens de financement de nos startups
et deux des acteurs du numérique les
plus innovantes en mobilisant nos
investisseurs institutionnels c'est ce
qu'on appelle les fameux fonds tibi que
nous avons développée au niveau français
que nous souhaitons développer au niveau
européen et qu'il s'agisse des domaines
les plus technologiques à la santé
numérique ou d'autres cela nous permet
de là aussi aller plus vite et plus fort
dans le développement de nos acteurs
numériques mais permettre aussi de
défendre leur souveraineté et d'éviter
que ces derniers lorsqu'ils sont en
phase de croissance les plus fortes
n'aille chercher cet argent chez les
anglo saxons ou les asiatiques
les dix premières capitalise les dix
premières capitalisations mondiales
aujourd'hui
voix huit entreprises de la tech et
aucune européenne c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui du capitalisme mondial et
donc
ce qui est une source d'espoir c'est que
parmi tout particulièrement ces huit
entreprises de la tech qui appartiennent
aux 10 capitalisation mondiale aucune
n'existait il ya 25 ans donc tous les
espoirs sont permis simplement il nous
faut regarder les règles de cette
compétition internationale pour y
arriver elles sont simples si on veut
arriver créer un vrai marché intégré du
numérique simplifier nos règles
supprimer les barrières entre les
vingt-sept et donc continuer à
travailler sur ce marché unique du
numérique à voir les talents et donc
continuer dans notre capacité en
européen à bâtir un agenda
d'attractivité des talents on a commencé
à le faire en franco français il nous
faut avoir cet agenda au niveau européen
troisièmement attirer les financements
c'est ce que j'évoquais à l'instant et
c'est le lien d'ailleurs avec une union
des marchés de capitaux c'est réussir à
mobiliser l'épargné institutionnelle des
européens vers l'innovation le risque le
développement de ces champions c'est un
élément essentiel pour bâtir le nouveau
modèle de croissance européen le
deuxième axe sur le numérique c'est de
ne pas subir la loi des autres
puissances en définissant nous mêmes les
règles pour le monde numérique je
l'évoquais encore il ya quelques
semaines au forum de paris pour la paix
nous avons déjà réussi en européen a
porté une réglementation européenne pour
la protection des données visuel non
seulement tu es c'est un succès sur le
continent européen nous avons amélioré
la protection de nos citoyens et de
leurs données mais nous en avons fait un
standard international
les grands groupes américains se sont
mêlés à ce standard ce qui montre que
quand nous savons nous organiser nous
créons des standards à l'échelle de la
planète
il nous faut poursuivre ce travail nous
avons obtenu un accord international sur
la taxation des multinationales et en
particulier des géants du numérique
l'agenda
de la présidence française permettra de
mettre en oeuvre cet accord qui a été
finalisé en jeu des vins au niveau
européen d'ici au printemps nous aurons
passé dans les conseil compétent
particulier le conseil dit ecofin les
textes permettant justement de mettre en
place ces deux piliers et donc de
parachever ce travail pour une vraie
taxation des multinationales ensuite il
y a deux textes pionniers qui seront
discutés avec le parlement européen et
sur lequel nous concentrerons la
présidence française le premier c'est
l'acte pour le marché numérique ou dma
qui vise à éviter que les géants du
numérique deviennent des monopoles sans
règles et tu cet esprit d'innovation qui
hier leur a permis d'émerger cet acte
pour le marché numérique c'est au fond
un acte de régulation économique
de ce secteur
le deuxième c'est l'acte pour les
services numériques d'idées est ça qui
établira un régime de responsabilité des
grandes plateformes au titre des
produits qu'elles vendent et surtout des
contenus qu'elle diffuse et ça c'est une
régulation inédite européenne pour
lutter contre la haine en ligne pour
définir la responsabilité de ces grandes
plateformes sur leur contenu ce qui fait
de l'europe un continent pionnier en la
matière
chaque jour nous avons à évoquer des
sujets qu'il s'agisse d'antisémitisme de
racisme de discours de haine de
harcèlement en ligne il n'ya aujourd'hui
à proprement parler pas de régulation
internationale sur ces sujets ce texte
sera fondateur en ce qu'il permet à
l'échelle d'un continent de mettre en
place pour la première fois une
régulation des contenus et une
habilités des plateformes ces deux
textes des m a aidé sa seront des
priorités sur ce volet numérique de
cette présidence française
enfin c'est le quatrième pilier de ce
modèle européen de croissance que nous
voulons mettre au coeur de cette
présidence ce qui doit distinguer le
modèle de production européen des autres
c'est notre capacité collective à
proposer aux travailleurs des emplois de
qualité qualifiés et mieux rémunéré
c'est au fond de dire comme d'ailleurs
le le rapport blanchard tyrol et
l'ensemble des économistes qui nous ont
remis il ya quelques mois dans ce
rapport sur le nouveau modèle de
croissance que nous voulons défendre ont
parfaitement dit c'est de créer les bons
emplois l'europe s'est toujours
construite sur ces deux piliers la
compétitivité la capacité à produire et
innover mais aussi sa capacité à avoir
des préférences collectives et des
équilibres sociaux et perdre penser les
équilibres de nos sociétés la justice de
celle ci et donc la capacité à créer de
bons emplois des emplois de mieux en
mieux payés à former ses salariés
si notre europe ne protège pas et ne
protège pas mieux les plus faibles si
elle laisse prospérer le dumping social
alors apparaît un marché sans règles ou
ne se retrouve plus les classes moyennes
et les classes populaires
c'est cette europe là qui a nourri le
break site ne nous y trompons pas
lorsqu'une partie de notre peuple
considère qu'ils sont les perdants d'un
système ils finissent par le rejeter
légitimement nous avons d'ores et déjà
obtenus ces dernières années des
résultats importants qu'on pensait
inaccessible je le rappelle il ya
quelques années sur le travail des
tâches et le changement de ces règles
l'accroissement de ses contrôles
j'étais encore hier d'ailleurs sur
un des plus grands chantiers de travaux
publics que nous avons sur notre sol
dans l'allier j'ai pu regarder la mise
en oeuvre des contrôles que nous pouvons
et dictée de manière très concrète grâce
à trait à cette réforme européenne que
nous avons initié mais cette présidence
doit être l'opportunité d'aller plus
loin et c'est pour cela que j'ai tenu à
associer les partenaires sociaux à la
préparation de cette présidence est
nous l'avons fait il ya plusieurs mois
en marge du sommet sous présidence
portugaise à travers une série d'
échanges bilatéraux nous allons avancer
durant ce semestre à venir sur plusieurs
sujets d'abord la directive sur les
salaires minimums dans l'union
européenne qui définit non pas un smic
européen comme une moyenne mais tire
tous les bas salaires vers le haut grâce
à un salaire minimum décent sera au
coeur de notre présidence les bonnes
discussions de la semaine dernière dans
le cadre du conseil
des ministres compétents a permis une
avancée considérable et nous pourrons je
le crois parachever cette avancée pour
véritablement créer un système beaucoup
plus efficace à l'envers tirant vers un
salaire minimum décent en europe et dans
tous les pays nous agirons aussi pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
avec la directive sur la transparence
salariale qui vise à mettre fin aux
écarts de salaires entre les femmes et
les hommes nous souhaitons également
les prochaines heures seront
déterminantes en la matière pouvoir
finaliser les textes européens pour les
quotas dans le cadre des conseils
d'administration ces textes étaient
bloqués depuis plusieurs années je pense
que nous pourrons finaliser ces textes
lors du prochain semestre et nous
souhaitons également faire avancer le
devoir de vigilance à l'échelle
européenne
voilà nos priorités sur ce deuxième
pilier que le modèle européen de
croissance qui en quelque sorte et notre
capacité collective à réinventer ce qui
nous a fait à l'aune du 21e siècle
savoir innover savoir produire savoir
reconstruire notre souveraineté
technologique et la justice sociale à
l'échelle du continent nous aurons aussi
apporter beaucoup d'autres sujets
majeurs sur l'union de la santé publique
sur les sujets de manipulation de
l'information d'agriculture
d'interdiction des pertes des pesticides
sur les rues des régions ultra
périphériques
sur le capitalisme responsable et tant
d'autres sur la compagnie accompagnement
d'un modèle agricole d'excellence mais
le fil rouge et la faire en sorte que
cette présidence soit utile qu'elle
permet à l'europe de s'affirmer en tant
que puissance et reprendre le contrôle
de son destin et d'affirmer la
singularité de son modèle enfin le
troisième grand axe que je veux ici
présentés et qui sera au coeur de cette
de cette présidence c'est ce que
j'appellerais une europe humaine
à taille humaine à l'échelle humaine
pour citer les grands auteurs et je
crois que cela contribue de cette
singularité qui est la nôtre
nous avons sur ce ce petit morceau de
terre qui nous a été donnée fait naître
la démocratie la renaissance l'humanisme
l'esprit des lumières les droits de
l'homme
avec toujours une vocation profonde qui
fait l'europe et qui doit continuer de
la faire une certaine idée de l'homme
et voilà pourquoi au delà des priorités
que je viens de présenter je veux que
nous puissions faire de cette présidence
française un grand moment d'humanisme
européen un temps de mobilisation pour
ce que j'appelle cette europe humaine
avec plusieurs initiatives là aussi qui
scanderont les prochains mois d'abord au
mois de mai nous aurons un conclure la
conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe
celle ci c'est une proposition que
j'avais pu faire au printemps 2010 9
elle a donné lieu à un immense travail
et je veux vraiment remercier partout à
travers l'europe l'ensemble des équipes
d associations d engager des jeunes en
particulier qui se sont investis dans ce
ce travail et qui va permettre de
déboucher sur des conclusions que au
moins de mai nous aurons à discuter avec
les institutions de notre europe avec
les gouvernements la société civile
cette étape importante d'abord parce
qu'elle est le fruit d'un travail
collectif d'une mobilisation mais parce
qu'elle est le début aussi de cet élan
aux fondateurs nous ne devons pas
chercher au mois de mai à avoir des
conclusions ficelé mais plutôt à essayer
de rebâtir un élan fondateur où nous
devons repenser cette vocation humaniste
de l'europe plus efficace
plus proche de nos concitoyens
je crois que c'est essentiel pour
qu'elles soient justement plus humaine
une europe qui se redonne quelques
ambitions simples une europe qui se
donne des règles pour mieux associer nos
concitoyens être résolument plus
démocratique et une europe beaucoup plus
simple ce qui est un agenda que nous ne
devons pas perdre de vue qu'ils étaient
essentielles cet élan peut-être ira
jusqu'à une refondation de notre été et
je me félicite d'ailleurs que
la nouvelle coalition en allemagne se
soit dotée d'une telle ambition je
rencontrerai demain pour la première
fois le chancelier allemand sur la fox
qui viendra à paris donc demain midi et
nous aurons l'occasion d'en discuter je
pense que cette capacité cette
disponibilité politique de plusieurs
états membres à embrasser ces nouveaux
sujets est essentielle pour que ce
rendez vous du printemps 2019 soit à la
bonne ambitions c'est à dire celle de
l'histoire et des prochaines décennies
nous porterons aussi comme nous l'avons
toujours fait la question des valeurs
qui sont le fondement même la raison
même de notre union nous connaissons les
débats actuels sur l'état de droit la
présidence française aura à les mener
pour en revenir dans les questions sur
le détail des procédures de tous ces
sujets mais je veux ici dire que d'abord
ces questions ne sont pas négociables
elles sont existentielle elles sont à la
base de notre été elles sont au coeur de
ce qui est la convention même des droits
de l'homme qui a précédé à notre union
elles sont dans les textes
constitutionnels de notre union mais ces
questions ne doivent pas opposer l'est
et l'ouest de notre continent elle ne
confronte pas des pays les sociétés ou
des peuples d'europe entre non
ils sont un combat politique
existentielle pour nos valeurs et pour
notre union il ya des forces politiques
qui remettent en cause ce qui est ce
socle de valeurs de droit qui a fait
notre europe et donc nous devons aussi
réfléchir à des nouveaux outils pas
seulement de sanctions mais également
d'encouragement d'accompagnement il ya
un travail politique profond car nous
devons aussi regarder des pays qui sont
en train de douter de la réalité ou de
l'efficacité ou la pertinence de ses
valeurs c'est notre responsabilité des
européens
faire c'est pourquoi entre autres je
souhaite que durant ce semestre nous
puissions trouver des nouveaux
instruments pour aider à faire vivre nos
libertés démocratiques et qu'en
particulier nous pouvons nous puissions
mettre sur pied un fonds de soutien
européen au journalisme indépendant et
d'investigation
ne mèneront ce combat pour la défense de
l'état de droit comme nous mais non le
combat pour nos valeurs celles de
l'égalité de la lutte contre toutes les
haines et toutes les discriminations
en visant à étendre la liste des
infractions européenne au crime et
discours de haine en nous dotant d'une
stratégie de lutte contre le racisme et
d'antisémitisme en dotant l'union d'une
législation sur la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
enfin l'europe c'est une histoire une
culture à nul autre pareil qu'il nous
incombe de porter de défendre et de
transmettre et cette europe humaine que
j'ai évoqué cet humanisme européen cette
appartenance que nous avons mis aussi au
coeur justement de cette devise
n'existe que s'il est charnelle sensible
c'est notre culture de repères notre
histoire ce qui passe par également
notre éducation
l'histoire européenne n'est pas
seulement l'addition de 27 histoire
nationale elle a une cohérence une unité
que chacun pressent mais qui ne se donne
pas avoir encore pleinement c'est
pourquoi je souhaite que nous puissions
relancer sous cette présidence française
un grand travail sur l'histoire de
l'europe mais un grand travail qui doit
se faire dans un cadre
historiographique indépendant nous
vivons un moment politique en europe où
le révisionnisme s'installe dans
plusieurs pays où le révisionnisme
historique est utilisé par des
puissances qui veulent remettre en cause
nos valeurs notre histoire parfois
revoir leur propre rôle durant notre
vingtième siècle nous devons absolument
bâtir un cadre académique où les
historiens de toute l'europe pourront
continuer à oeuvrer sur un travail
historique
indépendant reposant sur les traces
l'épreuve les controverses et je
souhaite que nous puissions mois de juin
prochain en france
initié ce travail qui donnera lieu à une
préparation ardue et scientifique par un
comité indépendant durant les prochains
mois mais de forger une histoire et une
historiographie
de notre europe et d'une histoire
mondiale de l'europe c'est indispensable
et sur la base de ce travail nous
devrons d'ailleurs considérer comment ce
travail pourra ensuite être décliné dans
chaque pays européen
l'esprit européen n'est pas seulement un
passé une flamme qu'il faut animer
rallumer chaque jour en manière sensible
dans nos écoles dans nos musées dans
notre culture
c'est pourquoi nous organiserons aussi
en juin prochain une grande réunion des
universités européennes
en effet lors du discours de la sorbonne
j'avais proposé que nous puissions créer
des universités européennes
nous avons été et nos universités ont
été extraordinairement efficace 40
universités européennes existent
aujourd'hui cela fait partie de ces
réalisations très concrète qui depuis le
discours de la sorbonne font que celui
ci est devenu une réalité nous réunirons
ses 40 universités plus toutes celles
qui se seront créés et peut-être dans
l'entre-temps en france afin de pouvoir
continuer cet agenda mais de consacrer
aussi l'importance des universités en
europe je souhaite aussi que cette
présidence soit l'occasion de créer une
académie d'europe qui réunira des
intellectuels de toutes disciplines les
27 états membres pour éclairer nos
débats éthiques
rapport aux libertés proposer aussi des
actions et des projets culturels
et puis pour que chacun puisse avoir
accès aux grandes oeuvres artistiques
qui nous font européen qui nous font
vibrer comme européen nous prendrons
plusieurs initiatives culturelles fortes
durant cette présidence d'abord d'ores
et déjà
tout ce que la france porte de culture
dans notre pays hexagone et outre-mer
mais aussi dans la représentation nos
sites culturels partout en europe et à
l'international s'est mis aux couleurs
et à l'ambition de cette présidence
française nous le ferons dans un temps
un peu particulier où nous aurons aussi
au mois de mai prochain célébrer les 30
ans d'arreter et d'une fierté culturelle
d'un grand projet européen mais nous
développerons plusieurs initiatives en
lien avec tous les partenaires qui
souhaitent nous accompagner en la
matière en déployant des micros folie
où nous aurons à travers tous les pays
toutes les régions toutes les villes
européennes qui souhaitent justement
s'associer à ce que nous avons pu mener
en france des initiatives pour
développer l'accès à des opéras des
musées des oeuvres d'art notre
sensibilité commune à travers des
organisations virtuelles mais qui
permettent dans telle ou telle commune
tel ou tel endroit où il n'y a pas accès
à des
établissements de culture d'avoir accès
à ses oeuvres nous l'avons développée en
france ces dernières années avec un
succès véritable nous le ferons au
niveau européen avec là aussi un point
de rendez-vous au mois de mai prochain
2022 sera là mais européenne de la
jeunesse
j'avais évoqué à la sorbonne une
généralisation du programme d'échangé
erasmus à tous les jeunes européens car
il donne une ouverture d'esprit qui est
un bagage unique dans la vie adulte nous
l'avons déjà élargi aux apprentis et
avons déjà doublé le nombre de
bénéficiaires et je veux remercier
toutes celles et ceux qui se sont
engagés dans ses ambitions dans cette
ambition et ont permis aux apprentis
partout en europe de bénéficier de ce
nouveau programme erasmus plus allons
plus loin y réfléchissons à un service
civique européen de six mois ouvert à
tous les jeunes de moins de 25 ans pour
un échange universitaire ou
d'apprentissage un stage ou une action
associative ce service civique européen
c'est une proposition que nous on fait
les jeunes européens et qui ont été
remises aux ministres compétents je
souhaite que nous puissions enclenché la
mise en oeuvre concrète et véritable de
cette initiative qui vient de notre
jeunesse
durant ce semestre cora a présidé la
france vous l'avez compris cette europe
plus humaine c'est celle qui à travers
toutes ces initiatives
permet dans nos écoles nos universités à
travers la culture
de défendre nos valeurs mais de faire en
sorte que ce combat pour l'europe ne
soit pas un combat d'entre soi
mais une lutte qui est toujours à mener
quand on considère que l'europe est un
acquis on ne se bat plus pour elle quand
on oublie que l'europe est ce qui nous a
fait ce qui nous force ce qui nous lie
on finit par penser qu'on pourrait la
désagréger sans conséquence et donc ce
combat est aussi existentielle que celui
pour la souveraineté et pour le modèle
de croissance que j'évoquais voilà le
triptyque autour duquel
nous organiserons ce semestre à venir
avec plusieurs rendez-vous que j'ai pu
égrainer au travers donc de ma
présentation ce sont les principaux mais
il y aura chaque semaine des réunions
ministérielles des réunions informelles
ou formelles mais cet agenda sera ainsi
scandé je ne serai pas plus long je vais
maintenant répondre à toutes les
questions que vous pouvez avoir ce que
je vous propose c'est que nous ayons
d'aborder des questions sur l'europe
tous les sujets sur l'europe évidemment
y compris les sujets qu'il n'ait pas pu
aborder pour parler notre présidence
parler ensuite peut-être des sujets
internationaux
je ne m'appesantirai pas sur les
questions de politique intérieure
française ce n'est pas l'objet de cette
conférence mais évidemment s'il y avait
quelques questions plus nationale je ne
les skis vrai pas mais ça n'est pas le
coeur de cette conférence
monsieur le président
bonjour
deux petites questions ensuite cette
longue présentation impression que vous
avez dix ans devant vous ça ça va plutôt
se résumer à deux mois et demi il peut
être plus si les français le veulent
bien
la première porte sur le les
investissements que vous souhaitez
intégrer au cadre budgétaire européen
est ce que cela signifie que vous me lit
très clairement pour l'abandon des 3% ou
modification de ce ces 3 % intégrant des
exceptions et les quelle est la deuxième
question plus politique vous allez vous
rendre en budapest 13 décembre pour
rencontrer un adversaire politique sur
la scène européenne viktor orban vous
aurez besoin de rassembler la famille
politique pour faire avancer tous vos
projets qu'est ce que vous attendez de
cette rencontre qu'elle quel deal voulez
vous passer avec lui qu'est ce que vous
attendez de lui sachant que lui aussi
est en campagne il n'a pas tellement
intérêt à vous aider
bien sûr première question d'évidence il
nous faut mener une politique
d'investissement sur toutes les filières
que j'évoquais et nous faut aussi mener
une politique d'accompagnement de ses
investissements sur le plan social ce
sont d'abord des financements européens
que nous devons être d'ores et déjà je
veux ici vous rappelez nous avons
commencé cette transformation nous
l'avons commencé grâce au travail franco
allemand puis européen
il y a quatre ans quand on disait quant
à la sorbonne je disais notre europe
doit changer ses règles budgétaires
notre europe doit bâtir des financements
commun notre europe doit avoir plus de
solidarité budgétaire visé belle idée
française les allemands diront toujours
non
nous l'avons fait pas des déclarations
nous l'avons fait avec la chancelière
merkel en mai 2020 parce qu'il y avait
la crise oui mais parce que nous avons
su réagir pendant ce temps à la crise
sur cette base là nous avons construit
un accord européen en juillet 2020
d'ores et déjà nous avons ces 750
milliards d'investissements en dur
c'est une vraie transformation du budget
et donc avec tout ça on peut déployer
des investissements qui n'était pas dans
nos budgets parce qu'au fond c'est c'est
presque plus qu'un doublement du budget
traditionnel parce que c'est sûr -
d'année et donc nous sommes en train de
déclencher aujourd'hui ses alliances
industrielles et ses grands
investissements de sortie de crise sur
ses nouveaux projets ses nouvelles
priorités et donc
le premier point la réponse c'est que
nous avons déjà construit commencé à
construire un cadre macroéconomique au
niveau européen solidaires pour faire
face à ces investissements ensuite nous
devons avoir une discussion stratégique
pour dire est-ce que c'est suffisant je
veux pas présenter cette discussion faut
qu'elle soit sincère donc on doit déjà
dire qu'est ce qu'on veut faire si on
dit on veut mieux se protéger qu'est-ce
qu'on veut investir en européen et au
niveau national chacun pour notre
défense pour nos technologies pour notre
climat sur cette base là est ce que
notre paquet de relance européen est
suffisant ou pas et ensuite il nous faut
décider s'il nous faut un plus grand
budget européen si on décide que ces
investissements sont communs ou s'il
nous faut certains investissements
nationaux qui sortent des règles et donc
je pense qu'il faut sortir de nos vieux
tabous et de nos vieux fétiche
la question c'est pas plus pour ou
contre le 3% elle est dépassée cette
question il faut des règles budgétaires
pour rester sérieux sinon il ya plus de
confiance il faut des règles de
convergence financière oui la question
c'est comment on articule le sérieux
budgétaire et la convergence entre
européens avec une ambition qui est
indispensable pour nous tous ça peut
être par la capacité à lever des
nouveaux financements en européen sur
les marchés comme nous l'avons fait pour
2 750 milliards ça peut être de dire
nous décidons d'avoir un plus gros
budget européen et donc plus de
contributions dans les années à venir
entre européens ça veut pouvoir dire
peut-être que nous décidons que chaque
européen sur tel était le sujet à une
catégorie de dépenses ou
d'investissement qui sort des rennes il
ya plusieurs solutions possibles je ne
veux pas ici les présenter mais il nous
faut aller vers une politique
d'investissement cohérente avec ses
priorités
je serai lundi en effet à budapest pour
rencontrer le premier ministre viktor
orban puis pour avoir une discussion
avec le groupe devise grade viktor orban
n'ayant la présidence de celui-ci
c'est en nous
imposant
mercer politique mais c'est un
partenaire européen autour de la table
je pense que c'est très important de
toujours rappeler cette grammaire nous
sommes 27 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement autour de la table quelles
que soient nos sensibilités politiques
nos choix nous devons travailler
ensemble pour notre europe et donc mon
devoir et je le prends comme tel depuis
le premier jour c'est de porter la voix
de la france de défendre les intérêts de
la france mais d'aider à construire des
compromis utile pour l'europe et la
france autour de la table
viktor orban c'est aussi faire ce
travail et donc il peut y avoir des
désaccords profonds et il y en a mais
notre devoir dans les prochains mois
c'est de permettre à l'europe sur
l'agenda que j'ai évoquées de continuer
à avancer il est très clair que sur le
sujet de l'état de droit il y aura de
désaccords évoqués tout à l'heure mais
je pense que sur les sujets de
souveraineté sur des sujets le modèle de
croissance sur les sujets multiples que
j'ai pu évoquer il peut y avoir aussi
une capacité à trouver des compromis
utile avec les vingt-sept c'est
d'ailleurs la condition pour avancer
c'est ce que nous avons aussi pu faire à
plusieurs reprises
la parole est à virginie malingre du
journal le monde qui est en
visioconférence depuis bruxelles
oui bonjour monsieur le président
je voulais savoir sur la pologne
en ce moment les discussions entre la
commission et varsovie qui n'avance pas
et qu'en même temps vous pensez que ça
peut durer des tas
de zoug résistance près de choses ou la
pollution attendent parce débauche où
les points de droit ou par ce biais tant
que la commission se classe quelle est
l'issue est est ce qu on sait que c'est
pas ça peut être dangereux pour la
construction européenne c'était ma
première question et je voulais aussi
savoir
[Musique]
l'ancien peut-être annonce mais vos
homologues d'ici
cinq ans comment on peut combiner une
constance du conseil de l'union
européenne électorale vous avez bien dit
en début de votre les discours que sont
liés mais concrètement qu'est ce que
vous leur dites comment vous commencez à
les réussir à rester honnête courtier
[Musique]
bon alors je dois dire que d'abord
l'orientation des micros au fait que
quand tu es une question qui est posée
même dans la salle celui qui est ici en
temps assez mal je le dis juste pour la
technique mais alors en plus c'est
encore plus dur en visio et j'ai aggravé
mon problème en vous posant une question
au milieu de votre deuxième question
donc du coup j'ai j'ai compris et
corrigez moi si votre première question
et sur l'état de droit
et alors est ce que ça couvre la pologne
et la hongrie ou uniquement la pologne
je n'ai pas compris et votre deuxième
question du coup je n'ai pas entendu le
début parce que j'étais en train de
parler
ma première question c'était vraiment
sur la pologne
sur les discussions en cours entre la
commission et grâce aux dix
ans
je voulais sera comment on attendait
mieux là tous les ans si vous pensez que
cet état gazeux
d'antan
et comment on peut en sortir et s'il ya
danger pour la construction
ma deuxième question c'était comment est
ce que vous allez faire pour
cumuler
deux rôles qui permettent aux
antagonismes celui de
la présidence française de l'union
celui de d'éventuellement candidat à
l'élection présidentielle en france
n'est pas encore mais que je serai
sûrement bientôt si beaucoup alors sur
votre première question vous avez
sur la pologne il y a deux sujets le
premier sujet
ce sont les éléments de conditionnalité
qui sont le fruit de notre accord
ni au plan de relance complété par le
parlement européen qui a fait un
considérable travail sur ce sujet et le
fait que dans les critères pour
bénéficier du justement du plan de
relance européen et des éléments d'état
de droit qui était suivi pour les
différents pays pour la pologne jan
critères de l'indépendance de la justice
de la justice et donc là il y à un
dialogue qui a été intense ces derniers
mois sur essentiellement des procédures
de destitution de certains juges et la
mise en place donc de chambre
disciplinaire qui ont procédé à ces
destitutions et comme vous le savez
l'expression sur la hiérarchie des
normes de la cour suprême polonaise
je pense que ce sujet qu'il
essentiellement le le fait d'une
discussion entre la commission
européenne et la pologne est un sujet
qui peut avoir
un débouché dans les prochains mois et
qui peut se régler dans les prochaines
semaines des prochains mois parce que il
ya eu suite aux différents échanges en
particulier de la chancelière de
moi-même et de la présidente de la
commission européenne du président
michel une avancée avec un engagement
pris par la pologne donc de démanteler
ces chambres disciplinaires et de
restituer ces juges et donc de montrer
que ces conditions étaient bien remplis
je ne sais pas dire aujourd'hui si nous
y arrivons je sais dire qu'il ya un
processus qui est en cours qui me semble
enclenchée avec des progrès mais nous
restons vigilants déterminée et c'est
les prochaines semaines qui nous diront
si ça avance ou pas et ensuite une
procédure qui elle est enclenché depuis
plusieurs années sur les bannières plus
large le sujet de l'état de droit
article 7 est donc celle ci elle je ne
pense pas qu'elle donnera lieu à des
avancées substantielles dans les
prochaines semaines sauf s'il ya des
initiatives prises par la pologne pour
répondre aux demandes très précises
faite par la commission européenne et
donc je pense en effet qu'elle
continuera à durer je vous entends
totalement sur le faite vous dire que
tout ça donne le sentiment de durer trop
longtemps
je pense qu'on peut avoir des résultats
encore une fois à court terme la grande
difficulté dans laquelle on est plongé
si nous sommes honnêtes avec nous mêmes
c'est que tout notre système a été pensé
comme si cela n'arriverait jamais
parce que nous n'avions jamais imaginé
qu'on puisse avoir une remise en cause
de ces principes là de ces normes
pendant des décennies l'europe sur ses
principes s'est construite comme
allant constamment comme reposant sur
une téléologie je dis bien téléologie
parce que tafforeau déjà dit théologie
et après ça me créé beaucoup de
problèmes et nous sommes en particulier
le jour de la laïcité et nous tenons à
ce jour important donc je dis bien
téléologie m et l'europe toujours pensé
le fait qu' on allait vers une europe de
plus en plus justement respectueuse de
ses droits fondamentaux et qu'on allait
vers une amélioration de ses droits nous
avons depuis plusieurs années un
mouvement que nous voyons à l'oeuvre qui
travaillent plusieurs pays et qui
d'ailleurs est aussi à l'oeuvre dans le
nôtre qui est le fruit de certaines
formations politiques mais qui
travaillent nos sociétés de remise en
cause de ses valeurs
et on ne peut pas faire comme si de rien
n'était donc il faut d'abord je dis
toujours un être intraitable avec nos
valeurs évidemment qu'ils aient des
procédures qu'elle ait des effets utile
deux qu'on s'interroge quand même sur
pourquoi tout cela devient quelque chose
se passe quand même dans notre europe
qui fait qu'il ya un ébranlement des
consciences et qu'on remet en cause ce
qui nous semble être une évidence j'ai
pas la réponse à ça mais ne faisons pas
comme si c'était un problème secondaire
parce que les dirigeants dont on parle
sont des dirigeants démocratiquement élu
par leur peuple
la troisième chose moi j'ai un objectif
quand même c'est d'essayer de convaincre
ses dirigeants mais surtout leurs
peuples et de ramener tout le monde à
nos valeurs en ayant fait cet examen
politique culturelle de profond que nous
devons faire en europe est un met en
garde dans d'autres unités je pense que
toutes celles et ceux qui disent il faut
couper quand ça va pas près d'une
responsable rôle de responsabilité est
ce qu'on pense que la réponse à tout ça
c'est de dire la pologne n'a plus rien à
faire dans l'union européenne moi je ne
pense pas et donc je pense qu'il faut
être très dur avec les dirigeants les
forces politiques évidemment les actes
qui ne sont pas conformes à nos
principes il nous faut en parallèle tout
faire pour combattre ses idées mais en
profondeur dans le substrat de la vie de
la nation et comprendre comment tout ça
peut être venir et être défendue par
certains concitoyens européens il nous
faut tout faire pour quand même garder
cette europe unie
sur votre deuxième question
je vous remercie d'avoir mis d'abord
hypothétique cette présidence française
nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas choisi
le calendrier
c'est comme ça et ce calendrier qui plus
est on ne l'a pas choisie il était
difficile de l'anticiper il ya plusieurs
années sinon d'ailleurs nous mêmes au
début où nos prédécesseurs l'aurait
bouger parce qu'il est le fruit aussi de
la mise en oeuvre du bric site qui a
déréglé l'ordre de nos présidences
est ce que pour autant
d'avoir essayé de bouger les choses mais
ceux qui viennent directement avant ou
après avaient eux mêmes des périodes
électorales et donc il nous faut tenir
notre rang notre rôle avec l'esprit de
responsabilité en considérant que c'est
la france qui a aussi une continuité que
les sujets dont on parle sont ceux qui
sont poussés depuis plusieurs années
qu'ils sont intérêts de la france et de
l'europe et donc je veillerai à faire
cela au demeurant j'essaie de le faire
depuis quatre ans alors est ce que
toutes les sensibilités politiques
qui dans le discussion démocratique qui
s'organisera en france dans les
prochains mois ont la même perception de
cet agenda à coup sûr non et donc
ça ce sera le je dirais la vie
démocratique de notre nation qui à
partir de la fin du mois d'avril dira
sur ces sujets les positions que tiendra
la france mais je pense que cette
présidence française ne pouvons la tenir
dans un cadre qui est le nôtre c'est à
dire en tant que président ski qui ne
fait pas pour autant la politique des 27
peut-être que la politique de la france
changera à coup sûr la france restera la
france en tout cas je ferai tout pour et
je le ferai durant les prochains mois
jusqu'aux échéances
électorales qui sont les nôtres croyez
le bien à côté de ça nous avons organisé
les choses pour que d'abord évidemment
la réserve soit respectée conformément
aux lois en vigueur pour que nos
fonctionnaires
nos équipes puissent continuer de vrais
servant l'état durant toute cette
période
et gouvernement a aussi organisé de
manière régulière des consultations
transpartisane compris avec les
parlementaires européens pour veiller à
ce qu'il y ait une juste information et
concertation durant cette période et que
ce soit apaisée c'est important
bonjour monsieur le président laurence
benamour agence france presse
un peu en miroir la question de ma
consoeur je vous demandais si les choix
que vous prenez pour l'europe ne vont
pas finalement contraindre limitée
encadrer l'action d'un futur
gouvernement en 2022 par exemple vont
ils empêcher une politique radicalement
différentes sur sur les étrangers sur la
construction de nouvelles centrales
nucléaires sur un retour à la rigueur si
vous ne parvenez pas à faire oublier les
3% de maastricht merci bon sur ce sujet
je vais répondre rapidement parce que je
ne vais pas répondre non plus xx x
je les dis et je vous le redis
le mandat que m'ont confié les
françaises et les français je l'exercé
ré jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure
et donc les défis qui sont les nôtres
qu'ils soient sanitaires qu'ils soient
migratoire qu'il soit énergétique
implique des choix
dites-moi la date à laquelle il faut
s'arrêter de travailler démocratiquement
c'est la fin du mandat et donc je
travaillerai jusqu'à la fin du mandat il
ya parfois des choix importants qu'il
faut faire quelques semaines ou quelques
mois avant la fin d'un mandat
si je suis devant cette situation je le
ferai et donc étant président
démocratiquement élu avec un terme
j'agirai en cette condition jusqu'à ce
terme
bonjour monsieur le président julien
lécuyer du journal la voix du nord une
petite question qui concerne
toutes les toutes les régions qui seront
intéressés par la reconquête
industrielle vous avez rappelé récemment
que notre région en où les rois de
france avait donné beaucoup à
l'industrie de ses paysages et de ses
vies et à l'heure actuelle elle a en
effet des grandes attentes autour de la
refondation industriels des grands pôles
de compétitivité et la question que se
posent certains des salariés qui
occupent ces
industries à l'heure actuelle c'est de
savoir si
dans l'avenir à l'avenir dans les mois
prochains est ce que vous serez le
fervent défenseur du champion européen
même s'il est à l'extérieur des
frontières de la france ou bien vous
ferez vous l'avocat de lattes cider
français pour permettre aux salariés
français de conserver leur antre merci
alors d'abord nous bâtissons une
politique française pour
être crédibles sur cette reconquête
industrielle
depuis maintenant quatre ans et demi
nous avons mis en oeuvre une politique
macroéconomique et microéconomique pour
aller en ce sens ce pas des mots la
reconquête industrielle sont des choix
des actes ce sont les choix budgétaires
et fiscaux que nous avons pris il n'y a
pas de conquête industriel s'il n'y a
pas de financement de notre industrie et
donc les choix que nous avons pris sur
le plan de la fiscalité au début du
quinquennat la baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés la baisse de la taxation du
capital ont permis de retirer
des investissements et des entreprises
en france et d'enrayer la
désindustrialisation
depuis deux ans nous avons enrayé une
baisse de notre industrie qui datait
imaginer le de 12 années douze années
nous avons vécu douze années de baisse
de l'emploi de l'investissement
industriel nous avons mis fin à ça
depuis deux ans c'est le fruit de notre
travail c'est ensuite le travail filière
par filière
d'investissements publics
d'investissement dans la formation de
nos chômeurs comme de nos travailleurs
et donc cette politique française elle
porte ses fruits et elle a commencé a
permis de réindustrialiser les chiffres
ont encore d'ailleurs été il ya quelques
jours mise en exergue qui montre que
n'avons jamais recréé autant pas
simplement d'emplois mais de projet
industriel que ces derniers mois le plan
de relance européen nous a aussi permis
de le faire pour vous dire que l'europe
ne conduit pas forcément à choisir entre
l'europe et la france et donc grâce au
plan européen que nous avons négociés on
a eu des financements de l'europe qui
nous ont permis à travers
france relance et maintenant france 2030
de bâtir des projets et d'aller beaucoup
plus vite la région de france en a
d'ailleurs largement bénéficié c'est
grâce à ces crédits que nous avons pu
attirer plus vite des projets de
batteries par exemple électrique à doué
ou d'autres sujets très concrets et qui
crée d'emplois industriels ou qu'ils
maintiennent
c'est grâce à ces projets européens
qu'on peut bâtir des nouvelles filières
agroalimentaire etc etc nous aurons
ensuite des alliances comme je le disais
avec parfois des champions a amené nous
défendrons la france partout mais
parfois il y aura des gros projets
européens les gros investissements
européens qui iront sur tel ou tel site
qui n'est pas forcément français ça
n'interdit jamais de défendre des
champions français aussi et d'autres
projets mais nous ne pouvons pas
évidemment considérer que l'europe
serait due à la france donc pour vous le
dire clairement 1 c'est une politique
qui est d'abord nationales si vous
n'avez pas le bon contexte
macroéconomique ce n'est pas l'europe
qui fait votre travail à la place deux
d'ores et déjà l'europe nous a permis
d'accélérer et de développer de la
réindustrialisation 3 ce sera dur en
même temps là encore grâce aux
financements européens nous aurons
plusieurs de nos champions qui seront
financés ou qui se créeront dans votre
région et ailleurs dans la batterie dans
le cloud votre région est ô combien
d'ailleurs un des champions de
l'infrastructure du cloud avec ovh
et nous continuerons cela et nous aurons
aussi des financements européens sur des
grandes alliances certaines rond des
sites en france d'autres non mais même
quand il y aura des sites hors de france
nous empêchera pas nous avec nos propres
financements nos propres politiques
évidemment de continuer de développer
d'autres acteurs et de leur laisser leur
chance n'aura pas de choix à faire
bonjour monsieur le président il ya ce
truc france télévisions première
question l'europe s'est endetté a fait
un emprunt commun pour financer le plan
de relance sur le colis des ce que vous
souhaitez que les vingt-sept fasse
d'autres emprunts communs sur d'autres
financements que le coc vite bref est-ce
que vous souhaitez pérenniser ces
financements commun est ce que vous avez
l'intention d'en parler avec olaf scholz
qui vient déjeuner avec vous demain
deuxième question valérie pécresse et
d'autres candidats de droite
principalement veulent réviser la
constitution pour que la france puisse
s'affranchir du droit européen surtout
sur le sujet migratoire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
alors sur les
sur les financements commun commencé à y
répondre à votre question tout à l'heure
à votre à votre confrère
c'est trop tôt pour dire s'il nous faut
aller beaucoup plus loin faut déjà
utilisé pleinement l'enveloppent qui est
la nôtre nous avons fait un pas
historique
d'abord en décidant du principe de
financement commun et d'un endettement
commun et solidaire sur les marchés ce
qui était un débat tabou jusqu'à ya un
an et demi et nous avons défini une
première enveloppe ne tombons pas dans
ce qui est parfois le défaut français
qui créent d'ailleurs du coup de
l'angoissé nos partenaires qui est dire
avant même de la savoir si on utilise
bien comment l'utilisent on en demande
plus parce que ça donne le sentiment que
au fond la dépense quelque chose qui se
crée soi même je pense qu'il faut
d'abord affiner notre stratégie
industrielle telle que je l'évoquais la
chiffrer avant le même chiffre en
européen regardez aussi nos dépenses en
matière de défense sur cette base là à
voir un consensus européen sur nos
besoins aussi en matière
d'accompagnement social de nos
transitions climatique d'investissement
climatiques et c est sur cette base là
on saura dire ce dont on a besoin mais
ça n'est plus un tabou et donc peut-être
qu'il nous faudra aller plus loin mais
il faut mieux le faire en sachant
pourquoi et sur quelle base quand on
procède comme ça on arrive à convaincre
les autres c'est exactement ce qu'on a
fait au moins 2 mai dernier ce que je
vois simplement c'est que nous serons
sans doute confrontée à ce besoin parce
que le monde dans lequel on vit je vous
le dis pour moi c'est pas un débat entre
je dirais les pays qui sont dépensés ou
pas dépenser comment le vivez avant on
doit sortir de cela pour regarder le
monde au fonds on a vécu pendant des
décennies la guerre civile budgétaire et
financière comme on avait vécu avant sur
d'autres plans maintenant nous devons
comme on l'a fait à chaque fois regardez
l'europe à travers le monde et nous
pensé comme une puissance de financement
des modèles de croissance moi je le
regarde à deux zones qu'est ce qu'on
veut faire on veut une europe qui créent
des emplois si c'est l'europe du chômage
ce sera l'europe de la guerre c'est
notre premier défi créer des emplois
créés d emploi créé des emplois l'europe
des années 1930 est une europe qui de
fait divisée avait choisi la déflation
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
regardez les choix budgétaires de pays
qui n'était pas alors unis mais qui dans
les conflits qui ont existé les choix
politiques nationaux sont allés vers des
chouettes déflationniste cette europe a
construit la guerre parce qu'elle avait
d'abord bâti le chômage et la défiance
nous devons avoir une europe qui regarde
l'avenir
l'optimisme et qui donne la confiance à
notre jeunesse qu on s'est embrassés nos
défis et créer des emplois l'europe du
plein emploi elle est décisif si on veut
garder une europe de la prospérité et de
la paix et donc s'il faut investir
100 milles pour cela il faut le faire
c'est un choix politique et
existentielle nous ne savons pas
aujourd'hui de chiffrer mais on voit
bien que parce qu'on l'a fait il ya un
an et demi
la france
grâce à ses réformes au niveau national
mais grâce aussi à cet élan européen
elle à son niveau de chômage le plus bas
depuis 15 ans 15 ans et elle sort d'une
crise qui est beaucoup plus dur que la
crise financière de 2008 2010 et donc
faut continuer son show de cette
croissance est plein emploi la deuxième
chose et géopolitique regardez ce
qu'investit la chine regardez ce qu'ils
investissent les états unis d'amérique
quand ils investissent sur leur
transition énergétique sur l'heure
numérique 100 ou 1000
l'europe ne peut pas dire investi 10
et dire on va faire des champions c'est
pas vrai et donc
quand on chiffres chaque filière si on
dit on va être les champions de
l'hydrogène moi je suis pour surtout que
nous on produit de l'électricité très
décarbonée on est champion d'hydrogène
commettre les autres on veut être
champion du numérique quels sont les
investissements sur les grandes
solutions numériques que font
aujourd'hui les chinois les américains
et qu'est ce qu'on fait en europe 1
c'est ça qu'il faut regarder parce que
la compétition est internationale
voilà c'est fait pour moi les deux
grands
sujets qui doivent éclairer nos choix je
ne me prononcerai pas aujourd'hui en
tant que président de la république sur
dd vous le comprendrez bien sur ces
sujets de campagne je n'ai pas fait le
choix de proposer une révision
constitutionnelle à nos compatriotes je
pense que nous avons en europe et ainsi
nous savons bâtir un pacte justement
migratoire efficace la possibilité de
manière très pragmatique
de construire des solutions d'abord pour
aider les pays d'origine et de transit
mieux protéger nos frontières et avoir
des règles communes moi je suis pour le
pragmatisme en la matière et donc c'est
sûr ce pragmatisme que dans les
prochains mois j'essaierai d'avancé sur
les solutions utiles et après il
appartient à chacun d'éclairer ce débat
faut pas en faire un débat je dirais
tabou pour les uns au totem pour les
autres sur ce qu'est la constitution
faut que ce soit précis simplement pour
savoir ce qu'on veut modifier exactement
et pour faire quoi et à quelle échelle
utile
catherine souligne les échos c'est une
question sur l'autonomie stratégique
il ya au début de la crise sanitaire le
gouvernement à demander à des
industriels est fabriqué des masques
dont la france manquait or un an et demi
plus tard on se rend compte que la
production est bien là mais elle n'est
pas écoulé parce que le produit sont
trop chers et qu'on continue à importer
massivement des masques de chine donc
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un problème là de
compétitivité est ce que ce n'est pas
même si c'est un peu anecdotique les
limites de cette indépendance
stratégiques alors sur ce sujet d'abord
vous avez raison de dire que pendant des
années en france et ailleurs nous avons
construit des dépendances parce que nous
avons pensé notre europe comme un marché
ouvert dans un monde en paix
et donc nous avons en quelque sorte
considérer que
l'être suprême était le consommateur
européen
moi je considère que
semer de l'édifice européen c'est le
citoyen et la citoyenne européenne
c'est-à-dire une personne qui est tout à
la fois qu'ils consomment mais qui
produit et qui veut être au coeur de
choix démocratique
décider librement librement
souverainement tout ça nous a conduit à
repenser la souveraineté est en effet
pour avoir visité plusieurs usines de
production de masques et nous expliquer
comment méthodiquement une rampe ouverte
qui ne regardent pas où elle fait ses
achats et où le simple critère qui
regardaient c'est le moindre coup fini
par dire il ya personne qui a le moindre
coût que les chinois et ont créé cette
dépendance nous l'avons nous avons deux
fêtes recréer des capacités de
production parce que tout était fermé
venant de la chine
et nous sommes en train de changer les
comportements est-ce que ça va assez
vite à mes yeux non alors il ya eu
parfois sur certains sujets d'achat des
nouvelles qui n'étaient pas tout à fait
juste
dans ce qui était dénoncée donc les
ministères compétents ont pu corriger
ces nouvelles quand elle sortait par
contre il est vrai que plusieurs
acheteurs publics ou privés ont parfois
repris leurs habitudes alors qu'il
reprenne une partie d'habitude ça n'est
pas illégitime parce que tout le monde
doit faire des choix et il ne s'agit pas
de faire de l'europe un continent
autarcique
car cela ne fonctionne pas non plus nous
restons un continent ouvert pour deux
raisons d'abord nous devons continuer
trouver un équilibre entre parfois
acheter le moins cher possible et garder
la souveraineté sur certaines
productions et parce que nous mêmes nous
avons l'ambition d'exporter vers
d'autres régions notre agriculture que
nous défendons elle exporte en dehors de
l'europe elle a besoin d'être défendus
hors de l'europe
donc voilà aussi savoir raison garder
par contre nous ne sommes pas assez
rigoureux dans l'achat européen c'est
pourquoi d'abord premier ministre à ma
demande depuis plusieurs mois procéder à
un passage en revue des achats non
seulement ministériel mais de tous les
acheteurs publics car vous savez que
l'achat public est extrêmement fragmenté
beaucoup d'acheteurs publics en fait
beaucoup de collectivités et les règles
sont en un établissement qu'on appelle
le gars pour que à côté de la simple du
ciom moindre coût tout en respectant ce
que notre droit pénal a mis aussi comme
contrainte légitimement dans les achats
publics on a un acheteur public ne fait
pas ce qu'il veut je tiens ici à le dire
parce que très vite sa responsabilité
pénale est mise en jeu et le favoritisme
et traquer à juste titre c'est le fruit
de dan et aussi de politique de
transparence et de lutte contre la
corruption mais tout en respectant ces
règles de favoriser l'achat européens
nous pouvons encore faire mieux les
choses se sont beaucoup améliorées mais
on doit encore aller plus loin et au
niveau des européens nous portons cet
agenda on est en train de le porter au
nom au niveau du fond européen de
défense où je peux vous dire depuis
trois ans c'est un combat homérique pour
convaincre certains de nos partenaires
de dire on a mis de l'argent dans un
fonds européens on va pas financer des
équipements qui sont faits hors d'europe
mais vous avez des pays qui défendent
d'autres choix et donc c'est un agenda
qu'on continuera à porter en présidence
donc ce monde est un parfait il ne sera
jamais totalement fermé pour de bonnes
raisons mais on va continuer de
l'améliorer mais stratégiquement il faut
aller vers beaucoup plus d'achats
européens et par voie de conséquence
aussi français n'est pas que français
pour permettre de défendre notre
souveraineté industrielle est
parfaitement raison
la parole est à jean quatremer du
journal libération qui est en
visioconférence depuis bruxelles
bonjour est ce que vous m'entendez ou
est clair
c'est parfait
ok donc je me pose la question je me la
remettre un petit peu en contexte parce
que c'est un sujet très poussée doit le
parlement européen va élire son nouveau
président en janvier et on applique son
de l'accord politique de juin 2019
conclu entre les socialistes les
conservateurs et les libéraux de
renaissance un conservateurs du ppe dont
doit succéder à la socialiste or le pb
de présenter la candidature de roberta
mais de cela une maltaise qui combat le
droit à l'avortement depuis qu'elle est
élue au parlement et qui vient même de
s'abstenir sur une résolution demandant
la criminalisation des violences faites
aux femmes le groupe politique
renaissance auquel appartient la
république en marche semble prêt à voter
en sa faveur une présidente du parlement
européen qui s'oppose au droit des
femmes exactement 40 ans après
l'élection simone veil est ce le symbole
de l'europe des valeurs que vous venez
de fermement défendre j'en profite pour
une seconde question c'est un bébé
sur l'espace de libre circulation
schengen que vous qu'elle vous semblez
particulièrement tenir et plus
aujourd'hui qu'à un souvenir les
contrôles aux frontières notamment
aériennes et ferroviaires sont devenus
la règle que ce sont des raisons de
sécurité des raisons sanitaires les
routes sont belles physiquement condamné
par exemple à la frontière espagnole
pourquoi ne pas assumer clairement le
retour aux frontières internes merci
merci beaucoup
cette question directe je reconnais
votre esprit piquant
sur la première question
je vais vous répondre pour ce qui me
concerne et faire peut-être une
clarification institutionnel pour ce qui
me concerne je défends et défendrai
toujours avec la plus grande force le
droit des femmes et en particulier le
droit des femmes à disposer librement de
leur corps est donc partout en europe il
y à des forces politiques qui remettent
en cause ce droit qui le fragilise je
ferai tout ce que je peux pour mieux
poser en respectant la souveraineté de
chaque état membre mais en le faisant
aussi dans notre pays parfois ces voix
s'élèvent c'est un combat que j'ai
toujours mené c'est un combat celui de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
que j'ai mis aussi au coeur de ce
quinquennat que j'ai mis avant que ce
soit un sujet de controverse et un sujet
si médiatique je tiens ici à leur
préciser quand d'ailleurs parfois les
mêmes qui sont les plus virulents
aujourd'hui pour le défendre
expliqué je m'en souviens comme si
c'était hier en octobre 2016 que j'étais
bien anecdotique à parler de la sécurité
des femmes dans les transports à
strasbourg en faisant le compte rendu du
premier débat que j'avais fait avec la
république en marche j'ai de la mémoire
et donc sur ce sujet je suis cohérent je
serai jusqu au bout
simplement je suis président de la
république française ce faisant je ne
suis pas le chef d'une formation
politique et je ne suis encore moins le
chef d'un groupe parlementaire européen
et donc de là où je suis je défend ses
valeurs avec force et je souhaite que
toutes et tous puissent les défendre
dans les enceintes où ils sont allés
porter qui en mon nom qui au nom de
combat commun
et je pense que c'est aux parlementaires
européens de choisir leur président et
leur présidente
j'espère qu'ils le feront avec l'esprit
de cohérence et j'espère qu'ils seront
en fidélité avec les combats qui sont
les leurs
je veux d'ailleurs dire ici que sur ce
combat
de nombreux membres du ppe et d'ailleurs
c'est parce que vous faites pas dire ce
que vous avez pas dit et je le précise
ici je pense que vous serez d'accord de
nombreux membres du ppe sont aussi
d'accord avec ses principes et les
défendent avec autant de force que moi
sur votre 2ème sujet
ce que vous décrivez est le risque
auquel nous sommes confrontés peut-être
même la réalité qu'à certains moments
ces dernières années nous avons vécu
schengen est un espace qui s'est
fragmentée
à cause de la menace terroriste
à cause de la tension migratoires à
cause de la panique sanitaires à trois
reprises
est ce que c'est une fatalité je ne le
crois pas d'abord sur la question
sanitaire vous aurez noté que la france
n'a jamais été sur ce sujet parmi celles
et ceux qui ont procédé à des mesures
unilatérales de fermeture ou qui ont été
vers des politiques non coopératifs
on a toujours tenu à une cohérence
européenne
ensuite la france par contre a remis des
contrôles aux frontières dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et les a toujours
et contrôle du coup aux frontières
massivement et compris sur des sujets
migratoires dans les zones frontalières
vous avez raison
on attire de lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est à adapter en fonction de
l'évolution de cette menace cela
existera toujours cela ne se substitue
pas à la coopération entre nos services
de renseignement une justice
le premier ministre lui-même il était il
ya quelques jours d'ailleurs en belgique
pour travailler sur ce sujet avec les
ministres compétents
la rénovation du code que la commission
présentera dans quelques jours ou
quelques semaines permettra d'ailleurs
de clarifier ses règles de même sur les
sujets migratoires mon souhait qu'elle
est il sait qu on est justement un
espace schengen qui soit plus efficace
et cohérent plus efficace à ses
frontières extérieures et plus cohérents
en interne pour éviter ce que vous dites
en raison de la crise migratoire
est donc ce que je propose me
semble-t-il est un élément de réponse
est ce que vous dites pour ne pas faire
l'acte de décès de ce qu'est schengen
cela suppose de repolitiser
dans le bon sens du terme cet espace de
dire ça doit être un sujet de
préoccupation de concertation de
coordination permanente des ministres
compétents ça veut dire ensuite nos
frontières extérieures sont pas la
frontière de la pologne de l'italie ou
l'espagne ou la grèce ce sont les
frontières européennes parce qu'à chaque
fois qu'on n'a pas des règles un
contrôle strict un engagement commun et
bien rentrer sur le sol européen des
femmes et des hommes qui à cet instant
sont soumises à des règles
qui deviennent très hétérogène et
nourrissent ceux qu'on appelle les flux
secondaire et la défiance entre les
états membres et ses mouvements
secondaire et donc on doit mieux tenir
nos frontières externes
politique de schengen renforcer pilotage
politique et on doit harmoniser nos
politiques d'accompagnement et nos
politiques d'asile et cdci si on fait ça
alors oui sur le sujet migratoires on
peut refaire de schengen un espace
ouvert parce qu on en refera un espace
de confiance et de protection mais ce
qu'on voit c'est que les réseaux
de trafiquants utilisent qui était
devenu une vulnérabilité pour faire de
l'europe un espace de trafic on doit
réagir à ça c'est ce qu'on a fait la
réponse est imparfaite elles le peuvent
il a réponse pérenne ça n'est que la
rénovation de schengen protections aux
frontières et convergence pour avoir des
règles communes sur ces sujets
frédéric haziza de radio j monsieur le
président vous venez de faire allusion à
l'humanisme européen aux valeurs et
l'histoire de l'europe alors dans le
prolongement de ce que vous avez dit je
voudrais pour y poser une question sur
les valeurs de la france et de l'europe
eric zemmour mais ni campagne haineuse
une campagne nauséabonde raciste crypto
pétainiste aux relents antisémites et
révisionnistes
il met en avant une haine anti musulmans
autour de la théorie du grand
remplacement ils cherchent à réhabiliter
pétain soi-disant sauveur de juifs remet
en cause le discours du vel d'hiv le
procès papon le discours du vel d'hiv de
jacques chirac et même l'innocence du
capitaine dreyfus alors les thèmes de
campagne du candidat zemmour sont ils
conformes aux valeurs de la france aux
valeurs de la république et aux valeurs
de l'europe
d'abord il n'appartient pas au président
de la république quel qu'il soit deux
qualifiés ou disqualifier un candidat à
une élection à venir
c'est au peuple français de décider
souverainement il y a des règles elles
sont contrôlées par le juge
constitutionnel
pour certaines autres plus technique par
le juge administratif
d'autres fois par le juge
et c'est au peuple souverain de choisir
donc je ne dirai pas si
ce qu'il convient de penser ou pas je ne
dirais qu'une chose
c'est que notre pays est
un vieux pays fait de valeurs de culture
de combat
et qu'il s'est à chaque fois grandi
d'avoir su regarder ces défaites mais
d'avoir su consolider ses valeurs
et aimer la france et respecter les
français
c'est au fond avoir une certaine idée de
la grandeur de la france
c'est respecter la dignité
de chaque française et de chaque
français
parce que c'est ce faisant respecter la
dignité de notre nation j'ai pas
d'autres commentaires à faire
merci
bonjour monsieur le président sophie
pradet reconnu mais j'ai une question
qui concerne un pays tiers
le royaume uni est la relation entre
l'union européenne et évidemment la
france
bilatérales avec la france vous avez pas
le passé souhaitent ses associés le
royaume uni plus étroitement avec
en matière de défense et sécurité avec
l'union européenne et pourtant il y à un
tel
méfiance entre les deux pays
actuellement et ça semble très difficile
en ce moment d'imaginer un tel dialogue
politique comment qualifiez-vous cette
relation actuelle et qu'elles sont des
conditions
d'une amélioration et d'un retour de
confiance nécessaire afin de partir
quelque chose
plus solide et plus constructives pour
l'europe dans le sens plus large
ensemble merci merci beaucoup
d'abord
la grande bretagne est une grande nation
elle aussi
voisines et amies
et notre histoire comme notre géographie
on n'échange pas nous avons plusieurs
centaines de milliers de françaises et
de français qui vivent qu'ils aiment ce
pays sa culture qui ont construit
leur vie et il y a
plusieurs dizaines de minutes quand même
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
britanniques qui aime autant la france
et qui ont construit là aussi leur vie
et ça on doit pas le remettre en cause
le fragiliser
il ya des désaccords avec gouvernement
actuel cet autre chose
et je veux avoir avant tout à voir ce
message à l'égard du peuple britannique
et voilà notre amitié parce que au fond
et dans la durée rien ne la remettrait
en cause après nous avons en effet
aujourd'hui des relations qui sont
difficiles mais elles sont difficiles
pourquoi parce que le gouvernement
actuel jusqu'à présent et j'espère que
les choses vont changer on peut se
réengager de bonne foi dans un un agenda
de confiance fait simplement ne fait pas
ce qu'il dit
il a signé un accord de retrait qui
impose sur la pêche
de tenir vis-à-vis de nos pêcheurs de
professionnels et d engagement la
journée de demain nous dira aux côtés de
la commission européenne si ces accords
sont bien respectées il ya eu ces
dernières semaines des progrès je veux
les saluer il ya un vrai engagement
sincère et j'espère qu'une nouvelle voie
s'ouvre vraiment je l'espère de toutes
mes forces
on a ensuite besoin de travailler de
bonne foi ensemble sur les sujets
migratoire le ministre a tenu une
réponse une réunion pardon importante il
ya de cela 10 juin calais
si on veut régler cette question de la
migration entre nos deux pays qui est
devenu une question humanitaire nous
avons besoin d'avoir un réengagement
britannique
puisque pourquoi ces femmes et ces
hommes sont là dans ces conditions
terribles parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
l'asile en france nous leur proposons
nous avons créé des centres en dur pour
cela nous amenons des centaines d'entre
eux dans ces centres nous prenons en
charge des dizaines de milliers de repas
tout au long de l'année mais ce sont des
femmes et des hommes qui veulent
rejoindre le sol britannique parce qu'il
n'y a pas de filière légale
d'instruction du droit d'asile fait par
les britanniques parce qu'il ya toujours
un système qui existe depuis les années
80 opaque où le modèle économique
britannique repose sur le travail
illégal d'étrangers si ces situations ne
sont pas réglés par les britanniques de
bonne foi nous aurons toujours ces
situations à nos frontières ou la france
à la bonne volonté de tenir ce point de
passage la réponse allait dans la
coopération britannique comme on dirait
chez vous vous êtes de chez nous
maintenant devrais je dire be my guest
que les britanniques seraient en gage de
bonne foi sur ce sujet
sur les questions de défense elles ne
sont pas remises en cause par le break
site
mais puis-je ignorer que les
britanniques ont été semble-t-il les
ardents promoteurs
d'un contrat qui
a délibérément combattu une vision
française en indo pacifique pour
construire une vision alternative et
exclusive
n'étant pas sans conséquence d'ailleurs
sur la prolifération dans la région asie
pacifique avec des conséquences
peut-être pas totalement imaginé dès le
début bon tout ça ne sont pas des signes
flagrants d'amitié
pour manu et manier länder statement
donc
j'aime la grande bretagne
j'aime son peuple
j'ai terriblement envie d'avoir un
gouvernement qui souhaite travailler
simplement de bonne foi avec nous
bonsoir monsieur le président marie
chanterait pour tf1 lci depuis quelques
jours plusieurs pays ont fait le choix
de boycotter diplomatiquement les jeux
olympiques de pékin divers je parle du
canada du royaume uni des états unis la
shoah la france pourrait-elle faire ce
choix prochainement merci beaucoup
d'abord je pense qu'il faut savoir
raison gardée de quoi parle-t-on
généralement quand on parlait d'un
boycott des jeux olympiques disait on
n'envoie pas nos sportifs on a connu ça
dans notre histoire à moscou ou ailleurs
personnes à travers le monde est en
train de dire on n'en voit pas nos
sportifs moi j'ai pas entendu
donc on parle quand même deux choses qui
sont beaucoup plus symbolique
juste pour remettre les débats à leur
juste proportion moi je préfère qu'on
travaille avec le comité international
olympique
pour évidemment que les chartes de
protection des athlètes compte tenu de
ce qui s'est passé ces dernières
semaines soit maintenu et pour que
véritablement on aide le comité
international olympique à faire ce
travail avec la chine pour que tous les
athlètes soient protégés pour que les
règles de l'olympisme partout à travers
le monde soit promu ensuite on
appréciera l'évolution de la situation
en lien avec les autres européens et
avec le cio je pense qu'il faut pas
politiser ce sujet surtout ce qu'on sait
pour prendre des mesures tout petit et
symbolique
faut être clair sont dit on fait un
boycott complet on n'envoie pas
d'athlètes soit on dit on essaie de
réengager les choses et d'avoir une
oeuvre une action utile comme toujours à
l'international je suis plutôt pour
faire des choses qui ont un effet utile
c'est avec le cio thomas bach et avec le
représentant du cio en chine et avec
toutes celles et ceux qui organisent
c'est comme ça qu'on va travailler avec
les ministres et avec nos partenaires
européens et on verra la décision qu'il
convient de prendre dans les prochaines
semaines en fonction des réponses qui
sont faites et de ce que la cie aux
faits mais laissons
d'abord ne politisent ont pas
l'olympisme ensuite car dont l'exigence
qui convient qu'aux pour que tous les
athlètes à travers le monde soient
protégés et soient maintenues dans leur
indépendance
bonsoir monsieur le président
françois-xavier bourmaud le figaro il ya
cinq ans vous aviez théorisé la
disparition du traditionnel clivage
entre la droite et la gauche au profit
d'un clivage notamment entre pro
européen et eurosceptique est ce
qu'aujourd'hui quand vous regardez le
paysage politique à la veille de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne vous diriez que le clivage
entre européens et eurosceptique s'est
creusée dans le pays et que la droite et
la gauche ont disparu
il dit qu'il va pas tellement de
commentaires de politique nationale
et donc je vais tâcher de continuer je
vois simplement que
nous avons fait la démonstration ces
dernières années que une europe plus
forte plus souveraine plus uni était
bonne pour la france
et que défend l'europe il ya quatre ans
était quand même plutôt une bonne chose
ne serions nous pas européen
bon courage pour les vaccins je dis
juste à titre d'illustration
parce que aujourd'hui nous n'avons
toujours pas de site de production sur
le sol national qui produisent de la rn
message et nous avons des grandes
entreprises françaises
qu'ils font dans des sites étrangers
nous faisons du rappel le film finish
nous sommes en train de développer une
filière mais au moment du début de la
crise n'en produisons pas chez nous nous
avons en europe et un bâti une
solidarité qui a permis d'acheter puis
de produire en europe et 1 et d'exporter
dès le début
moi je suis fier d'être européen quand
je regarde la crise sanitaire parce que
nous nous sommes battus nous avons
innové nous avons nous européens trouver
des vaccins nous avons acheté des
vaccins en européens et nous avons su
nous organiser pour produire ce qui fait
qu'au moment où je vous parle l'europe
et l'espace géographique qui produit le
plus de vaccins au monde nous avons
dépassé les 2 milliards de doses
produites
l'espace qui en a le plus exporté est
donné
c'est quand même beau long et donc pour
la défense de nos compatriotes
vacciner en janvier 2021 sans l'europe
n'ait pas été possible c'est ça la
réalité nous n'aurions pas pu le faire
nous aurions été à ce moment-là
dépendant d'achat nationaux avec
beaucoup d'incertitudes peut-être de la
non coopération est sans doute ces mêmes
sur ce qu'ils produisaient sur leur sol
de la rn messager seul le regarder pour
eux
tout ça vous donne de manière très
pratique ce que c'est qu'être européen
parfois on a le sentiment d'être
solidaires avec les autres on a aussi
bénéficié d'une vraie solidarité mais
nous avons réussi à avoir une politique
forte que la france a promu avec
plusieurs autres et qui nous permet
d'être des vrais champions en france
aujourd'hui on produit des vaccins on
assemble et nous sommes au coeur de
cette stratégie voilà c'est une bonne
chose donc je continue à penser que en
effet
promouvoir une europe plus forte plus
souveraine plus indépendante est une
bonne chose nous l'avons montré que ça
reste vrai demain et je pense que quand
on défend l'europe il faut la défendre
complètement folle a corrigé faut se
battre contre ces traverses et
complexité bureaucratique parfois ces
dévoiements mais on peut pas dire j'aime
l'europe
mais j'aime pas son édifice juridique
j'aime l'europe mais les traités ne sont
pas applicables chez nous
ça c'est de la drôle d'europe cette
affaire tient pas longtemps
donc européen oui je crois que ça reste
vrai il ya des gens qui continuent
à la vilipender
les français jugeront
sylvie corbet statut de presse tout au
fond
voilà
vous avez évoqué l'importance des
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne il ya notamment une crise qui
se déroule en ce moment en ukraine le
président biden cette semaine a repris
la main les négociations concernant les
tensions avec la russie est-ce que la
seule à sin selon vous la fin du format
normandie est ce que vous y voyez une
forme d'échec européens à faire une
médiation et est-ce que vous avez des
craintes comme halo exprimer certains
diplomates sur le fait que le président
biden pourrait demander à l'ukraine de
donner des gages à la russie pour
pacifier la situation
d'abord je pense que c'est de très
bonnes choses et je l'en remercie que le
président biden est jugé utile de se
coordonner avec ses partenaires
européens avant d'avoir parlé au
président poutine et après je pense est
une initiative qu'on n'avait pas connu
ces dernières années et qui est très
bonne politique qui donne de la
substance à ce que c'est que la relation
transatlantique
donc nous avons eu ce débat avec nos
quatre européen et président américain
ensuite je pense que ça ne se substitue
pas cette coordination format qui
existent président biden a lui-même
d'ailleurs dans les communiqués qui l'a
tué m rappelé l'importance de ce qu'on
appelle le foreman normandie qui je le
rappelle est ce format qui est une
médiation
franco allemande avec la russie et
l'ukraine autour de la table
ce travail continue et il a permis
d'éviter ces dernières années la
détérioration et nous a permis aussi
d'avoir des vrais résultats moi je veux
saluer à cet égard d'abord le choix de
mettre en place ce format qui était le
choix de la chancelière merkel et du
président hollande leur engagement puis
l'engagement très fort
ensuite dans la continuité à mes côtés
de la chancelière merkel qui a vraiment
consacré beaucoup de son temps à ce
sujet
nous avons préservé ce faisant une
situation qui aurait pu dégénérer nous
avons obtenu des résultats ici même en
décembre 2019
mais il est vrai que cette situation
demeure très dur instable et que nous
sommes
dans une main un conflit qui demeurent
gelés
est ce que c'est est ce que les
européens ont la possibilité de changer
cela au seul nom ça dépend de la bonne
volonté des autres partis et donc notre
souhait c'est de pouvoir réengager en
lien avec le président zelensky que je
verrai mercredi et en lien avec le
président poutine que j'aurai la semaine
prochaine également en ligne
réenclencher ce format est un processus
politique
notre objectif je crois à nous tous
européens et
aussi à nos partenaires américains
c'est d'abord d'être aux côtés de
l'ukraine pour assurer sa sécurité
ensuite c'est d'assurer une situation
pacifiant la région fait d'être
intraitable avec la sécurité des
européens dans la région et enfin c'est
de continuer à engager un dialogue
exigeant avec la russie parce que soyons
clairs nous sommes tous les cinq
d'accord les quatre européens les
américains sur une chose c'est par un
dialogue exigeant avec la russie qu'on
peut construire des solutions nouvelles
et un processus qui préserve la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et la
pacification de celle ci la pacification
toute la région et la stabilité de tout
notre continent vous noterez que ce sont
des positions que je défends depuis un
petit moment je pense que ce n'est pas
dans l'escaladé des tensions même s'il
faut toujours être exigeant et fermes
sur nos principes on a besoin d'avoir ce
dialogue est d'ailleurs par cette
discussion le président biden a montré
et penser aussi qu'il fallait un
dialogue avec le président poutine parce
que c'est par ce dialogue qu'on peut
acter nos accords et notre désaccord
mais aussi bâtir un chemin parfois des
digues
éviter d escalade
bonjour monsieur le président en juin
niveau d'eau france info est ce que ce
soit vous ne jouez pas un peu sur une
confusion institutionnelle
on comprend pourquoi mais vous vous
placez impatiemment devant devant les
français devant vos électeurs un peu
comme le président de l'europe pour les
six prochains mois
rappelons que le président du conseil
européen s'appelle charles michel et que
la france comme ses marques et derrière
vous présidez le conseil de l'union
européenne et pas de l'union européenne
est ce que ce soir vous ne pouvez pas un
peu sur cette ambiguïté qu on peut
évidemment comprendre un point de vue
politique merci beaucoup d'abord ce
n'est pas un jeu
parce qu'on parle de sujets importants
on parle du quotidien de nos
compatriotes
ensuite je pense savoir constamment
rappeler que nous parlions d'un semestre
et il y à une présidence du conseil
européen qui est président charles
michel que vous m'avez entendu cité à
plusieurs reprises avec lequel j'étais à
quelques instants et si votre question
est de savoir si j'ai vocation à me
présenter pour lui succéder à
l'hémistiche notre conseil puisque j'ai
compris qu'il y avait beaucoup de sujets
d'élections non
et mais il ya un semestre ou en effet la
france aura la présidence tournante
présidence tournante pour ça que par
d'un sommet donc je crois avoir été
précis
factuel mais le rôle de la france c'est
de présider les séances mais la
présidence tournante ça n'est pas
simplement une fonction hôtelière fait
une fonction aussi d'inspiration
c'est une fonction de déclencheur et de
construction de consensus autour de
choses comprends vous l'avait aussi vu
quand l'allemagne avait la présidence on
a permis pu construire des choses parce
que vous avez un effet de traction
je n'ai pas attendu cette présidence
vous serez d'accord avec moi pour
proposer essayé de pousser discours de
la sorbonne doit dater de septembre 2010
est la france n'avait pas de rôle
particulier
j'ai toujours été je suis cohérent j'ai
défendu l'europe quand beaucoup la
conspuer qu on la faisait siffler je les
portais j'ai proposé des choses on a
d'ailleurs agi et obtenu des résultats
sur la base de ces propositions la
france à la présider et je serai dans
mon rôle président qui porte cette ce
rôle institutionnel qui lui doit
permettre de construire des consensus
indépendamment des intérêts de la france
mais aussi promoteur d'un agenda qui
correspond à ce que nous voyons et nous
voulons pour l'europe ya toujours ce ce
rôle duhalde à une présidence tournante
elle est bien tournante
une toute dernière question s'il vous
plaît puisque nous arrivons au bout
d'une heure de questions ce n'est tout
dernier
bonjour bruno jeudy paris-match bfmtv 22
heures max ma question concerne une
grande région européenne et ultra
marines et la nouvelle calédonie
dimanche les habitants de cet archipel
sont appelés aux urnes pour la troisième
fois au terme du processus dit de des
accords de matignon
certains vos adversaires politiques
interprète votre silence comme une forme
de d'abandon ou de trop grande réserve
de ces îles pourquoi ce silence
d'abord j'invite chacun
[Musique]
la période conduit c'est toujours
cruel pour celles et ceux qui ont des
responsabilités parfois depuis plusieurs
années
mais j'ai sans doute moi même conclu ont
concouru en d'autres temps à ces mêmes
injustices quand j'étais dans une autre
fonction troll donc j'ai beaucoup de
distance avec cela mais quand les
tympans pratiques sont là des voix se
lèvent qui font comme si rien ne s'était
pas depuis quatre ans ou cinq ans
oserais-je dire que comme président de
la république je suis allée nouvelle
calédonie chili et passer plusieurs
jours je suis retourné pour la première
fois par exemple a ouvert et j ai tenu
un discours où j'ai été très clair
je crois avoir dit que la france serait
moins belle sans la nouvelle calédonie
ça me semble clair
et ça ne sommes pas l'abandon
après
le gouvernement de la république et le
président ont un rôle à jouer là aussi
et notre rôle a été inédit quant à la
nouvelle calédonie c'est la seule
mandature qui aura eu à organiser les
trois référendum décidé il ya plusieurs
années
le 12 décembre se tiendra le troisième
référendum est le dernier du processus
décidé
et les trois sous son mandat
conformément exactement à ce qui avait
été écrit est prévue
notre premier rôle sic ils se tiennent
en bon ordre dans de bonnes conditions
de sécurité de sincérité
le gouvernement est à la tâche et je
l'en remercie premier ministre le
ménisque et autres maires ministre de
l'intérieur aussi
ensuite c'est que le jour d'après soit
un jour possible quel que soit le choix
fait lors de ce référendum
rôle du président de la république n'est
pas d'être dans un camp parce
qu'aujourd'hui je parle à des femmes et
des hommes qui sont toutes et tous
dans notre nation et quel que soit le
choix nous aurons à bâtir le jour
d'après
beaucoup oublient dans ces périodes
quels que soient les sujets que ce qui
fait notre force c'est notre unité
qu'on peut porter
des choix ici ou là c'est respectable
qu'on peut les défendre
mais que nous avons à vivre ensemble et
pour la nouvelle calédonie c'est la même
chose le jour d'après quel que soit le
choix
il y aura une vie ensemble compte tenu
de la réalité géopolitique de la région
et de ce qu'est la nouvelle calédonie et
donc voilà la fonction qui est la mienne
la place qui est la mienne
jusqu'à une dernière question en forme
dernière question
monsieur le président bonjour allison
tassin pour tf1 et lci vous avez annoncé
la fermeture des discothèques
vous avez interdit de danser dans les
bars et dans les restaurants est ce que
ces mesures seront pour vous suffit
notamment pour sauver les fêtes pour
noël et puis par ailleurs je me fais le
porte voix de plusieurs de mes confrères
serez vous candidat à la prochaine
élection présidentielle
merci
chacun se souviendra
d'abord que
fut de l'ambassadrice de vos collègues
pour porter cette question donc j'ai
compris ces derniers jours qu'elles
étaient parfois obsessionnel
mais
que sans doute non pour la première fois
dans notre histoire
nous aurons une question alliant la
candidature à la présidence de la
république et les discothèques
ce qui peut-être d'ailleurs
est une invitation à la fête et la
source de promesses je veux le prendre
comme ça en tout cas
le gouvernement premier ministre et des
ministres ont tué en effet à présenter
des mesures complémentaires dans un
moment sanitaire qui est je le dis très
très sensible et qui nous avons tous
notre rôle à jouer je ne serai pas long
mais je veux ici vraiment remercier tous
les professionnels à qui on a demandé un
effort et tous nos compatriotes je le
dis parce que j'ai croisé ces derniers
jours plusieurs responsables des
événementiels de discothèque qui se sont
sentis stigmatisés par cette mesure or
ils ont parfaitement joué les règles du
jeu la difficulté c'est que dans
beaucoup d'endroits où on demandait le
passé ni terre comme on vous l'a demandé
ici comme on l'a tous mes ou
parce qu'ils avaient le pass sanitaires
il y avait des moments de soucier de
sociabilité de d'interactions très forte
on pouvait boire et manger à proximité
il a été prouvé je pense on contrôle du
ministre qu'on pouvait ce recompte aminé
parce que certes le vaccin permet de
réduire très fortement et les derniers
chiffres encore sorti ce matin sont très
bons même sur des variants mais permet
de réduire la circulation mais pas
totalement et dans ces moments de
convivialité qu'il y avait et qui dans
les salons qui ôte on serait infectée et
c'est vrai que dans les discothèques les
bar dansant comme on dit c'est le cas
donc on a demandé un effort pour essayer
de tenir notre stratégie repose sur la
vaccination la vaccination la
vaccination il nous faut continuer à
vacciner les premières doses et les
rappels
l'objectif ça a été rappelé par le
conseil scientifique et plusieurs autres
ces derniers jours sont d'ailleurs très
bon à cet égard nous sommes entre 600 et
700 milles vaccination deux jours c'est
en train de monter et donc c'est une
très bonne chose seuil que nous avait
donné le conseil scientifique font ce
qu'on trouve c'était 500 milles on était
à 700 milles hier donc il faut que nos
compatriotes continuent d'aller se faire
vacciner pour le rappel ou la première
dose c
la meilleure protection
y compris ce fameux rappel vous permet
de réduire très fortement la circulation
des variants les chiffres qu'ils ont été
sortis par les meilleures revues
scientifiques ces dernières heures le
montre encore aux états unis en israël
le deuxième levier c'est le pass
sanitaires la france a fait ce choix au
début de l'été c'est ce qui permet de
mettre beaucoup de contraintes sur les
non vaccinés et d'améliorer le contrôle
c'est ce qui nous a permis d'augmenter
la vaccination de réduire les risques
faut le garder c'est ce qui nous permet
je vous le rappel de tenir tant et tant
de lieux de culture des changes de vie
ouvert
et puis le troisième ce sont les gestes
barrière complémentaires et dans les
lieux où ce n'était pas possible c'est
là on a dû faire ces restrictions on va
continuer avec cette stratégie est ce
que dans les prochains jours il faudra
adapter je ne sais pas vous le dire
aujourd'hui
nous évaluerons
en début de semaine prochaine
l'évolution parce que vous savez qu'il
faut toujours un petit peu de temps
d'attentes pour regarder sur l'incidence
il faut quelques jours et il en faut
encore plus sur l'hospitalisation et il
faut encore davantage sur les soins
critiques on connaît maintenant le
rythme est donc ce qu'on regarde
beaucoup évidemment aujourd'hui ce sont
les chiffres d'hospitalisation et de
sens critique
l'incident ce qui est très forte
à un peu moins de sens que dans le temps
nous n'avions pas le vaccin et les
moyens de protection par contre nous
restons très vigilants pour voir
l'évolution à l'hôpital parce
qu'évidemment nous devons continuer de
protéger nos hôpitaux nos soignants et
dans un temps où il ya d'autres
pathologies qui arrivent les grippes
l'ebon hawk iolite pour les plus petits
ou
où les urgences sont là on va
s'organiser les plans blancs ont déjà
été décidées et donc c'est ça qui
conduira à des décisions ou pas
supplémentaire voilà donc je ne sais pas
vous dire si c'est suffisant je pense
qu'en tout cas c'est ce qu'il fallait
faire au vu des informations qui étaient
les nôtres et qui était proportionnée
pour donner de la visibilité et
permettent de nous protéger
je ne répondrai évidemment pas aux
dernières questions ce jour mais je veux
simplement vous dire mais c'est normal
que vous la pose y est je respecte tout
à fait et je pense que d'ailleurs si
demain je sais pas où je suis je suis
dans la nature et que l'un d'entre vous
là vous me la posent ray
et je prends très bien
d'abord je le prends comme un signe
d'affection
un désir caché
presque un appel
plus sérieusement
je pense que
dans le temps qui est le nôtre
est important que
les institutions continue quand même à
fonctionner de la manière la plus la
plus stable possible
plusieurs d'entre vous ont posé des
questions sur nos valeurs nos principes
quand les vents mauvais revienne
et se lève
il est légitime qu'il y ait des choix
démocratiques et que toutes les voix
s'expriment mais le rôle de nos
institutions
et d'obtenir le pays là où il doit être
ne rien concéder ni au racisme ni à
l'antisémitisme ni à la remise en cause
de nos valeurs ni à la manipulation de
notre histoire et ça c'est à nos
institutions de le faire
avec calme et autorités
je pense que notre pays on a besoin dans
les temps que nous vivons parce que nos
compatriotes
ont quand même vécu deux années si
difficile
ces moments dans la vie d'une nation ne
sont pas rien
beaucoup ont perdu des proches
dans des conditions humaines terrible
certains souffrent encore de ce qu'on
appelle le coc vie de long vivent la
solitude
sont dans les difficultés profondes
économique et social vivent une angoisse
je pense à part en particulier à nos
jeunes qui est aussi le propre de cette
période
est donc mon rôle dans ce moment
est de continuer à agir au service de
notre peuple pour protéger prendre les
décisions parfois difficiles pour
protéger
d'accompagner
et de préserver notre unité
parce que nous en avons besoin et quels
que soient les choix démocratiques qui
sont faits au printemps prochain et ils
doivent se faire dans le calme
plus grand pluralisme la plus grande
liberté de discussions d'échangés de
controverse car la controverse c'est
l'esprit français
mais la haine c'est la haine de la
france
et donc rôle du président de la
république c'est d'éviter cela donc pour
ce faire
je pense qu'il est bon de de veiller en
tout cas à ce que ce cadre se respecte
et je vous remercie pour votre attention
pour vos questions nous serons amenés à
poursuivre de toutes façons ces échanges
et pour votre temps merci à toutes et
tous
merci monsieur le premier ministre
18h24 sur figaro live un petit peu plus
de deux heures de déclarations et de
conférence de presse du président de la
république plusieurs annonces plusieurs
des propos qui ont été tenus bien
entendu autour de
la candidature éventuelle du président à
sa propre succession on va y revenir
tout au long de cette émission point de
vue spécial consacré 100 % à ces deux
heures donc de rencontre avec la presse
et le gouvernement on vient juste de
l'entendre puisqu'on entend bien
d'entendre le emmanuel macron remercier
jean castex on va faire d'abord le point
avec
jim jarrassé du service politique et
puis ensuite il s'appelle la serre du
service international du figaro enfin
florentin colons qui était à l'elysée
viendra nous rejoindre pour faire la
débrief le débrief économique et nous
donner son point de vue sur cette
conférence de presse
[Musique]
bonsoir gym j'ai assez sûrement semble
volo dit également avec jaime jara c'est
ce que vous avez pensé de cette
conférence de presse vous avez été
nombreux à la commenter qu'est ce que
vous en retenez d'abord quelle est votre
impression gym 2 par rapport à cette
conférence de presse qui a été quand
même très préparée qui a été qui a fait
l'objet de plusieurs annonces et d'une
communication abondante de la part de
l'elysée et du gouvernement et peut-être
un peu trop de communication vinson j'ai
envie de dire puisque en effet il ya eu
un teasing de la part de l'elysée et des
des principaux ministres concernés assez
important vis-à-vis de cette conférence
de presse il faut quand même rappeler
que c'est la seconde conférence de
presse des manuels mâcon sur le
quinquennat donc c'est un exercice
plutôt
inhabituel qui forcément attire
l'attention des français et des médias
donc on a regardé avec beaucoup
d'attention cette conférence on
s'attendait justement à ce que
emmanuel macron pts rennes justement
l'occasion de cette conférence de presse
pour faire un premier jalon sur la route
de sa campagne en vue la présidence la
présidentielle et puis finalement on
s'est rendu compte que emmanuel macron
est dans une forme de 'business as
usual' c'est à dire qu'il nous a
sorti les meilleurs tubes du président
sur sur l'europe sur l'immigration sur
le climat sur la relance sur la défense
etc c'était finalement une forme très
classique il n'a pas du tout renverser
la table et donc y avait vraiment cette
volonté ans je pense de rester dans une
forme de présidentialisation et pas du
tout de rentrer dans une nouvelle phase
qui serait la phase de la campagne alors
il a parlé d'une question obsessionnelle
bien sûr c'est la candidature à la
présidence de la république plusieurs
questions dont la dernière la question
qui était posée par alison teinte tf1 et
à chaque fois ils refusent de poser de
répondre à cette question il dit qu'il
n'a pas y répondre pour autant est-ce
que c'est le discours d'un président ou
est-ce qu'il a complètement abandonné la
posture du candidat non non c'était
doivent vraiment c'était là c'était un
discours de président il a voulu montrer
peut-être justement vis-à-vis de ses
adversaires qui sont en train
d'accélérer dans la campagne je pense
évidemment à eric zemmour qui a fait son
grand meeting aval villepinte le
week-end dernier et puis valérie
pécresse qui a remporté le congrès des
républicains il veut montrer qu' il ya
des institutions qui sont fortes et qui
sont tenues au niveau de l'elysée qui
continuera à présider jusqu'au dernier
quart d'heure c'est son expression qui
revient à plusieurs reprises et que
qu'est ce que ça veut dire clairement il
dit qu'il va prendre juste de rentrer
dans l'arène qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
vous décryptez justement derrière cette
déclaration
d'insister justement qu'il présidera
jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure ben
justement que
à la fois sur les sujets nationaux et
sur les sujets européens à travers cette
présidence française qui il faut le
rappeler est prévu pour durer un
semestre et va donc en jambes et
finalement l'élection présentielle et
ben et bien et compte assumer cette
fonction de président du conseil de
l'union européenne jusqu'au dernier
moment alors évidemment il ya un il ya
un moment à partir de mars où ça va être
très compliqué où là on il va y avoir
une une balance qui va ce qui va
s'opérer emmanuel macron va prendre les
habits probablement
on le verra du du candidat mais en tout
cas pour l'instant il déroule son
programme pour la présence de l'europe
comme s'il n'était absolument pas
concernés par l'élection présidentielle
alors refus de faire un commentaire sur
la politique nationale les français
jugeront dit il sur eric zemmour qui a
été mis sévèrement en cause par frédéric
haziza de radio j le président répond ce
n'est pas au président de disqualifier
un candidat ce qu'il convient de dire ce
qu'il convient de penser ou pas pareil
sur kant est mentionné le nom de valérie
pécresse d'un autre côté
on a dit moi si je me trompe et entendu
à chaque fois le président leur répondre
dans ce que chacun de ces candidats
alors en fait là on voit un président
qui finalement est dans la continuation
de la stratégie qui avait été la sienne
lors de la présidentielle de 2017 c'est
à dire jouer l'affrontement entre deux
camps et et nourrir le clivage entre
d'un côté les européens le camp anti
souhaite incarner alors même si là il
apporte un certains nombre de nuances
sur réforme et l'europe asseoir la
souveraineté européenne
et puis aussi renforcé peut-être une
certaine forme de
d'identité
nationale au sein de l'union européenne
mais quand même c'est le camp européen
face aux eurosceptiques
alors là on a évidemment le souvenir de
ce qui s'était passé en 2007 avec avec
marine le pen et ce clivage très fort
qui s'était mené à risque marine le pen
qui à l'époque était
notamment sur la question de l'euro très
engagé contre l'union européenne
aujourd'hui on retrouve encore ce
clivage qui continue à exister avec
marie le pen avec eric zemmour même si
les positions ou un peu bougé et donc on
retrouve un président qui sera
probablement candidat qui cherchent
encore une fois installé ce clivage avec
la défense d'une europe qui serait
finalement l'échelle parfaite pour
régler tous les problèmes des français
alors c'est sûr ça que je voulais en
venir avec vous on a quand même des
formules qui sont fortes objectivement
passer de l'europe de la coopération à
une europe puissante en six mois un
nouveau modèle européen de croissance
d'ici 2030 qui doit être présenté forger
une histoire de notre europe c'est exact
c'est également sa formule
et on le voyait également dans la mise
en scène avec en plus une introduction
par secrétaire d'état aux relations aux
affaires européennes clément bonne
est-ce que
il n'ya pas justement la volonté
d'afficher une ambition est derrière ça
justement donner une coloration à ce qui
va ou peut-être sa campagne alors tout
le défi pour emmanuel macron est en
effet sur sa présence d'abord un défi de
communication
c'est à dire alors il a parlé de ce
qu'il appelle l'europe humaine c'est à
dire rendre l'europe concrète parce que
pour beaucoup de français l'union
européenne est un monstre administratif
un peu froid qui est non pas souvent de
bureaucratie européenne avec
parle de bruxelles voilà deux espèces de
choses complètement désincarné et donc
et manuellement technocratique voilà la
technocratie emmanuel macron essaye de
rendre cette cet écheveau
institutionnels un peu plus concret pour
les français et donc il veut sur tous
les sujets sur l'immigration sur le
climat sur l'emploi sur le social sur la
défense donc finalement tous les sujets
qui vont faire l'élection présidentielle
qui s'annonce montré que et bien ces
enjeux là se joue à l'échelle européenne
et puis que les français ils essayent de
défendre
l'appartenance d'une des français une
forme d'identité européenne à cesser la
mission qui va être certainement là la
plus compliquée c'est pour ça que c'est
pas parce qu'effectivement c'est parce
que c'est parce que montrent les
sondages c'est parce qu'à celle publiée
par services c'est parce que montrent
les sais pas ce que montrent les
sondages qui montrent qu'il y ait une
forme pas de désaffection mais plutôt de
désintéressé à dire que les c'est pas
que les français sont contre l'europe
ils sont ni pour ni contre en fait c'est
à dire que c'est un échelon qui ne les
intéresse plus ils ne savent plus
vraiment ce qui s'y passe et finalement
ils ont l'impression que
l'europe leur échappe complètement et
c'est peut-être pour ça que vous le
rappeliez
emmanuel macron et clément bonne ont
commencé leur conférence de presse par
quelque chose de très concret qui est
une pièce de deux euros ils ont présenté
la nouvelle pièce de deux euros qui sera
mis en service par la présidence
française de l'union et en fait c'est ça
l'europe le plus le symbole le plus
concret de l'europe c'est finalement la
monnaie qu'on échange tous les jours
pour aller acheter un paquet de
cigarettes
au tabac et bien c'est c'est quelque
chose de très concret et donc ça va être
le défi pour cette présidence d'essayer
de ramener quelque chose de très froid à
aux réalités réalités des français
clément ghosn à d'ailleurs rappelé que
la pièce que l'on a vu et fabriqué à
côté de bordeaux dans l' usine de
fabrication des pièces historiques de de
pessac c'est une façon également de
vouloir justement rattachée
les français à l'europe est de montrer
que la france
l'europe se fait notamment en france oui
c'est s'est en effet montré ce double
échelons qui est pour emmanuel macron
quelque chose de complètement
enchevêtrés qu'on peut pas complètement
distinguer c'est à dire qu'on est à la
fois dans la tête encore une fois des
maniaques monde emmanuel macron français
et européens et que les deux vont de
pair
alors je parlais tout à l'heure la
stratégie d' emmanuel macron qui est
dans la continuation de celle de 2007
ça va quand même être c'est une
stratégie qui est qui et quand même
risqué puisque on parle du désintérêt
des français vis-à-vis de l'europe on
voit là qu'on est finalement sur une
conférence de presse qui était très
technique avec des grands thèmes et des
grands enjeux qui ont été envahis
représentait vraiment avec isabelle
carré flanquera cola à grand chose de
très concret alors il ya eu cette idée
de d'imposer un service civique européen
donc pour les jeunes c'est à dire qu'ils
puissent aller exercer leur salle
civique dont il se trouve que c'est déjà
quelque chose qui est qui existe déjà
mais il n'y a pas par exemple quelque
chose de très symbolique comme l'a été
le programme erasmus qui a été mis en
place
il ya déjà une vingtaine d'années qui
avait qui a marqué vraiment les toute
une génération d'européens l'a peut-être
que dans cette conférence de presse il
manque une annonce un peu phare qui
aurait pu marquer symboliquement le
début de cette présidence
bien passage quand même assez long sur
l'immigration et les frontières et la
volonté de refermer de réformer schengen
est ce que
pareil l'objectif est européen pour
emmanuel macron ou bien l'objectif est
national qui fait cette annonce et c'est
pareil il est doublé là ça va être
vraiment l'un des enjeux clés 1 de la
campagne présidentielle à quel
échelon va se jouer la gestion de la
crise migratoire en france ou en europe
emmanuel macron dit de façon très claire
c'est au niveau européen au niveau de
l'espace schengen qui va falloir
renforcer et donner plus de moyens
frontex pour protéger les frontières
extérieures de l'europe etc c'est dans
cet espace commun qu on se protégera
collectivement face aux vagues
migratoires face
d'autres d'autres candidats qu'ils sont
qui sont les candidats du camp
souverainiste et qui eux disent c'est
d'abord la france qui doit se protéger
elle face à ces vagues vie et nous et
non dans une forme de solidarité
européenne en tout cas la réforme de
l'espace schengen on a bien compris
maintenant que c'était quelque chose qui
était absolument inévitable quel que
soit finalement les camps politiques il
ya une forme de caen sens du consensus
qui s'installe d'ailleurs ça fait quand
même pas mal d'années qu'on nous en
parle là emmanuel macron remet ça sur
sur le métier mais c'est une c'est une
vieille réforme qui a déjà été
enclenchées
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que on est on
est vraiment dans ce qui va être au
coeur de la campagne présidentielle
en quoi sa ou son successeur s'il n'est
pas élu sera tenu par ses engagements
alors ça c'est une vraie question qui
lui a été posée d'ailleurs pendant la
pendre la séance de questions par les
journalistes et il a esquivé
cette réponse mais c'est une vraie
question puisque finalement on peut être
sûr un basculement philosophique
absolument radicales sur la question de
l'europe si jamais on a un candidat du
camp souverainiste qui l'emportent sur
cette présidentielle et qui devra
reprendre le flambeau sur la fin
les dernières semaines de la présidence
française et donc on a du mal à voir
comment ce candidat si ces hypothétiques
mais c'est possible va pouvoir reprendre
à son compte
tout ce programme qui a été présenté et
qui est un programme
très fédéraliste très pro-européens dans
l'esprit du discours la sorbonne qui
avait été celui de d'emmanuel mâcon et
qui à mille lieux de ce qui incarne un
certain nombre de candidats aujourd'hui
dans la présentielle donc je pense que
finalement la
la présence française s'arrêtera
clairement avec l'élection
présidentielle si valérie pécresse est
élu est ce qu'elle peut continuer
justement une partie des annonces des
manades macron oui je pense qu'il ya une
forme de compatibilité entre sur sur
beaucoup de sujets sur la question du
climat de la relance de la gestion du
cosy delà d une défense européenne je
pense que il ya beaucoup de deux sujets
sur lesquels emmanuel macron et valérie
pécresse peuvent se retrouver à
l'exception peut-être notable de la
question migratoire puisque valérie
pécresse défend sous la forme d'un
référendum constitutionnel une
finalement la possibilité pour la france
de déroger à certaines règles
européennes et là c'est un point
absolument de divergence totale avec
emmanuel mâcon qui lui dit d'abord que
il ya une suprématie une primauté du
droit européen y compris sur les
questions d'immigration et que est donc
là on est vraiment sur une divergence
stratégique majeur donc sur certains
sujets oui sur d'autres ça peut être
compliqué derrière question gym se met
donc sur l'afrique en février une
conférence sur les belles princesses un
jeu l'a assommé sur l'avenir économique
de l'europe en mars l'agenda est très
ambitieux est ce qu'il pourrait être
aussi tenu et aussi bien tenues kemal
mâcon le prétend c'est une notamment la
question pose guillaume tabard s'est
passé c'est aussi une vraie question
parce que il faudrait pas que
la présidence française
transforme en piège pour le candidat
macron c'est-à-dire qu'ils soient tenus
par une myriade d'engagement pour ses
ministres comme pour lui sur des
conseils européens qui finalement sont
des grands raoult qui sont très
éloignées des réalités de ce que de ce
que vivent les français et de ce que va
être la campagne présidentielle telle
qu'elle s'est lancée on l'a vu avec les
grands meetings
et la ferveur qui s'installent autour de
cette campagne on a le risque d'avoir un
président et un candidat qui sera tenu
par des engagements et qui finalement
on peut se retrouver un peu piégé il ya
une forme de ligne de crête qui va
s'installer pour emmanuel macron entre
tenir justement cette présence française
et ses engagements institutionnels comme
président de l'union européenne et puis
quand même rester dans une forme de on
va dire de
d'action
peut-être un peu subversives tel qu'il
l'était en deux en 2017 pourrait être un
candidat qui monte qui s'est encore
surprendre et imposer ses thèmes dans la
campagne présidentielle en tout cas il
nous a pas surpris ce soir ce soir
absolument pas c'était très convenue et
en tout cas c'est là comme que merci
beaucoup de nous a redonné votre point
de vue est votre analyse gym bien sûr on
retrouve toutes les informations tous
les récits tous les comptes rendus du
service politique et toutes les les
regards également du service politique
dans les pages du figaro dans les
minutes qui viennent et bien sûr dans
l'édition papier de ce vendredi on va
regarder maintenant ce qu'il faut en
retenir sur les répercussions
internationales de et les répercussions
internationales possible et les
engagements internationaux d'emmanuel
macron au cours de cette conférence de
presse au cours de ces déclarations avec
isabelle lasserre mais peut-être un
petit rappel sur ce qu'il a dit déjà au
début de la conférence de presse on
écoute s'il fallait résumer en une
phrase l'objectif de cette présidence
qui s'étendra du 1er janvier au 30 juin
je dirais que nous devons passer d'une
europe de coopération à l'intérieur de
nos frontières à une europe puissante
dans le monde pleinement souveraine
libre de ses choix et maître de son
destin et c'est ça l'objectif que nous
devons poursuivre pour la première fois
en effet depuis près d'un demi-siècle
des questions existentielles nous sont
posées sur le plan climatique sur le
plan technologique
sur le plan géopolitique qui impose et
c'est ce que nous préparons déjà vous
savez depuis plusieurs années de
profondément transformé notre
organisation de nous doter d'une
ambition nouvelle
j'avais eu l'occasion de présenter cet
agenda dès l'automne 2010 est à la
sorbonne et nous avons déjà parachever
beaucoup des objectifs qui avaient été
alors annoncée
mais ce travail aujourd'hui est rendu
encore plus indispensable par le
contexte que j'évoquais à l'instant
alors ses priorités
et la construction au fond de cette
souveraineté européenne est ce modèle
européen nous avons travaillé toutes ces
dernières semaines avec les différents
états membres avec le président du
conseil avec lequel j'étais il y à
quelques instants la présidente de la
commission avec lesquels j'ai échangé
lundi évidemment le président du
parlement européen qui était avec le
premier ministre ministres affaires
étrangères il ya quelques instants comme
avec les groupes parlementaires et
j'étais à leurs côtés le 2 décembre
dernier à strasbourg pour un longue
échanges pour préparer cette présidence
bonsoir il avait la serre on rappelle
que vous êtes là correspond diplomatique
du figaro spécialiste des questions
stratégiques et bien entendu donc de
politique étrangère un particulier de
celle de la france qu'est ce que vous
retenez de ces annonces ce soir écoutez
c'est une conférence de presse
relativement classique
au niveau international il a parlé un
petit peu de bail dun d'europe en
général de de son voyage en pologne et
en hongrie
en fait c'est un petit peu une une
réponse à la réponse
qui a été faite par le nouveau
chancelier par le nouveau pouvoir
allemand au discours de la sorbonne
d'emmanuel macron en 2017 souvenez-vous
vincent le président français avait
attendu pendant six mois une réponse
dans gala merkel qui n'était absolument
jamais venu elle lui avait reproché
d'avoir des ddd des programmes des
mesures proposées pour l'europe à un
moment où elles étaient empêtrés dans
les négociations de sa coalition et elle
l'avait laissé dans le dans le silence
et au lave ses olaf scholz le nouveau
chancelier allemand qui a répondu en
fait à emmanuel macron par son programme
de coalition qui reprend
les unes certaines propositions du
discours de la sorbonne donc depuis deux
jours en fait la balle était dans le
camp européen et emmanuel macron lui a
en partie répondu reprenant rebondissant
sur sur certaines des propositions du
sens et des allemands alors justement
vous allez voir un petit peu plus clair
sur quelles propositions du chancelier
allemand ce soir emmanuel macron qui
recevra d'ailleurs olaf scholz demain
donc
alors tout ça tout ça est quand même pas
très fin très très globale ya en fait il
ya deux choses qui risque de coincer
avec l'allemagne parce que ce qui est
intéressant c'est ce qui risque de
coincer c'est d'abord les questions de
rigueur budgétaire puisque la danse dans
ce discours emmanuel macron indiquent
les 3% du pib s'était c'est révolu ça
appartient n'existe plus après c'est
comme ça il faut des règles il faut la
reille des règles budgétaires mais
effectivement les 3% c'est du passé
c'est choisissez évolue donc c'est là
c'est là que ça c'est là que ça risque
de coincer parce que même si l'allemagne
a un pouvoir qui est beaucoup plus
ouvert sur les autres questions aux
propositions françaises la question de
la rigueur budgétaire va continuer à
opposer paris et berlin
le nouveau ministre des finances
allemand n'a pas du tout l'intention de
reproduire l'expérience du prg du plan
de relance pendant le coc vide et la
deuxième question qui risque de coincer
sur lesquels il est resté assez vague ce
soir dans sa conférence de presse et
pour cause d'ailleurs parce que c'est
surtout la france qui porte ce projet
c'est le sait le projet d'autonomie
stratégiques européennes alors
l'allemagne bien sûr il ya fait allusion
dans son programme de coalition
avant-hier en parlant de souveraineté
européenne et ça veut pas dire la même
chose pour la france et pour l'allemagne
alors précisément est-ce qu'on peut
d'ailleurs expliquer ce concept
d'autonomie stratégiques européennes et
où il y at il des divergences entre la
france et le le l'autonomie stratégique
européenne pour faire pour faire cours
en france c'est avoir les capacités
militaires
d'intervenir en cas de crise et surtout
pouvoir décider de manière autonome
e
dans ces crises sans avoir à dépendre
des états unis par exemple donc il ya
quand même une question de notions chez
macron de pouvoir militaire la défense
au sens hard du thème en allemagne ça
veut pas ça veut pas dire qu'il a
annoncé d'ailleurs de là que
l'organisation d'exercices militaires
conjoints au niveau européen on le voit
souvent au niveau de l'otan est ce que
au niveau européen ça peut ça peut se
faire et ça peut porter des fruits la
principale démonstration de la défense
européenne
selon selon la france est selon macron
c'est un combat c'est la force c'est la
force européenne au mali et au sahel
qui est en fait un regroupement de
forces spéciales européennes dans
laquelle beaucoup de petits pays comme
l'estonie par exemple participe alors
c'est à la fois symbolique au niveau
très très fortement symbolique au niveau
politique et au niveau militaire assez
assez anecdotique mais c'est mais c'est
vraiment le début mais l'allemagne
l'allemagne ne pense à ça c'est pas du
tout l'allemagne a parlé de souveraineté
européenne c'est énorme en fait jamais
l'allemagne ne parle comme ça donc on
peut toujours voir le verre à moitié
plein ou à moitié vide ou à moitié plein
enfin l'allemagne réalise que les
etats-unis ne seront plus toujours là
pour épauler l'europe et en même temps
le verre à moitié vide c'est que
l'allemagne parle essentiellement de
compétences civiles pour l'allemagne la
souveraineté européenne s'est développée
la santé les vaccins les nouvelles
technologies et l'allemagne et pacifiste
elle n'a aucune ambition militaire pour
son pays
il affirme que les objectifs du discours
de la sorbonne ont été atteints ce c'est
vrai que c'est faux non pas tous
une partie mais pas tous mais bon il y
avait quoi 50 propositions dans le
discours de la sorbonne donc il est bien
évident que elle ne pouvait pas tout
cette peut-être est-ce qu'il a réussi
par rapport au discours de la sorbonne
bas notamment salle amorce de l'europe
de la défense je crois pour lui
c'est quand même c'est quand même le
plus important
l'autre objectif c'est la réforme de
schengen jusqu'où peut-il aller
à l'entendre peu pourrait même évoquer
la le retour des frontières entre
membres de l'espace schengen ça c'est
l'autre question qui
qui posera forcément des problèmes dans
la présidence à qui va être très très
compliqué à gérer pendant la présidence
française de l'union européenne
parce que sur sur ce sujet comme sur
d'autres mais surtout sur ce sujet c'est
à dire la circulation et l'immigration
parce qu'en fait c'est lié il ya un
schisme il ya une division extrêmement
profonde en europe c'est avec d'un côté
les anciens pays de l'est sont les pays
d'europe orientale et d'europe centrale
qui sont pour la fermeture des
frontières
davantage de pouvoirs aux états et une
meilleure protection des frontières et
es10 immigration ces pays sont
d'ailleurs rejoints par des pays qui ne
sont pas en europe centrale et orientale
comme le danemark et de l'autre côté il
ya les pays d'autres fois l'italie de
solvin oui absolument parce qu'en fait
il ya deux divisions il ya une division
géographique et une sur division en fait
au sein de chaque pays avec des peuples
qui de plus en plus pense de cette
manière là donc en fait c'est très
compliqué parce qu'il est emmanuel
macron il est là il est la france est un
peu au milieu elle est là la position de
sa géographie dirais-je et en même temps
européen alors là où elle rêve c'est
intéressant je sens où dit elle la
position de sa géographie il ya une
ambition qui est également affichée
c'est un sommet un rapprochement avec
l'afrique un sommet union européenne
afrique peut-il convaincre les
dirigeants européens en la matière de se
rapprocher de l'afrique on a
l'impression qu'il voudrait
amener l'europe dans une dans la
politique de relations avec l'afrique
qui avait jusqu'à présent la france
c'est à dire que oui en fait emmanuel
macron est dans une période là où ils
essayent de absolument tout européaniser
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord parce
qu'on lui a reproché de faire cavalier
seul et d'avoir été trop arrogant donc
maintenant il européenne is to là le
dernier sommet sur la libye l'a
complètement européaniser jusqu'à avoir
proposé la réponse à cela la présidence
la coprésidence aux allemands et à
l'italie et ensuite parce qu'il s'est
aperçu que ce qui marchait en solo il ya
encore quelques années ne marche plus en
solo c'est à dire que aujourd'hui la
france n'a plus assez de puissance de
levier dans ce monde
complètement chaotique dans lequel les
puissances des puissances révisionniste
qu'on appelle à byzance révisionnistes
et la chine la russie malachie celle qui
révise soit les frontières soit
l'histoire nos machines la russie l'iran
la turquie et donc la france seule ne
peut absolument plus elle est
indispensable la france comme moteur
pour essayer de régler les crises mais
elle ne peut plus les réseaux tout seul
d'où la volonté d' européaniser
l'européanisation c'est d'arriver
à combler par l'europe des lacunes
maintenant que la france rencontre
a entraîné notamment sur les vaccins à
la fin doit entraîner l'europe dans un
projet qui initialement et français qui
est à petit un très très bon français le
problème de d'emmanuel macron c'est pas
le c'est pas le manque d'énergie et le
manque de d'idées et de visions le
problème c'est qu'il est quasiment le
seul en europe à avoir cette énergie et
cette vision est que la souveraineté
l'autonomie stratégique en europe il est
le seul à porter comme ça justement il
s'appelle pourquoi il est le seul à
avoir cet honneur 7,7 cette énergie
cette vision parce que les autres sont
léthargique ou bien parce que les autres
ont d'autres visions les deux mon
général les autres sont des tares gic du
moins en tout cas le sont plus que nous
c'est normal le seul couac à calmer les
pays du triple a donnée lors de l'europe
pour des révisions l'économie qui
semblent établies qui n'ont elles sont
là je parle je parle du pouvoir des
pouvoirs régaliens et je parle de dodo
mission globale la france est le seul
pays d'europe avec une vision globale
aujourd'hui c'était jusque là il y en
avait deux c'est la grande bretagne et
la france aujourd'hui depuis le
breakbeat n'ya plus que la france ceci
s'explique à la fois par part par la
culture militaire et par l'histoire
ancien pouvoir colonial un siège au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu tout ça
donne à la fois une culture une habitude
une une puissance et des responsabilités
dans le monde dont j'insiste c'est une
question qu'on pose avec thierry de
montbrial y est mais en 2014 on a vu
qu'il y avait vraiment une fracture au
sein de l'union européenne sur justement
ces visions à l'époque les pays d'europe
centrale et l'allemagne avaient les yeux
rivés sur une menace qui était la russie
et en particulier avec ce qui se passait
en ukraine ça se passe encore maintenant
tandis que la france elle était attaquée
et 2014 2015 avec des attentats et elle
avait les yeux rivés sur le sahel et sur
l'afrique encore plus de d'autant
qu'elle était déjà engagée au mali et là
on a vu une vraie fracture est-ce que
c'est pas ça le fond du problème et
est-ce que c'est pas ça qui rend vain
toute volonté toute velléité d'autonomie
stratégiques européennes alors en tout
cas ça rend vain pour l'instant où toute
possibilité d'avoir une politique
étrangère
commune bien entendu parce que chaque
pays au sein de l'europe à la politique
de ses frontières même si l'allemagne
veut avoir une politique un ministre des
affaires étrangères mais le problème
c'est que effectivement la menace n'est
pas la même selon qu'on se place à l'est
de l'europe qu'on se place au sud il a
annoncé parmi les autres mesures une
conférence aussi sur les balkans
occidentaux décryptage très très
important les balkans occidentaux on est
aujourd'hui à une période d'extrême
tension où on est arrivé au bout du
modèle qui avait été proposé par les
occidentaux notamment les accords de
dayton en bosnie qui ne marche
absolument pas et là on est vraiment en
train de se demander si il ya deux
problèmes il ya d'une part à nouveau ces
pays cette bosnie herzégovine
pourrait à nouveau basculer dans la
guerre avec des volontés sécessionnistes
des deux partis serbes et croates qui
veulent rejoindre leurs maisons mères la
serbie et la croatie à nous retournerons
à venir on retourne et deuxièmement des
influences de plus en plus importante à
la fois économiques politiques de
justement des puissances révisionniste
la russie la chine et la turquie qui
sont aujourd'hui des puissances qui
s'investissent dans les balkans et nous
nous déstabilise à partir des balkans
donc de raisons de s'intéresser vraiment
balkans occidentaux sur la pologne et la
hongrie
je trouve est frappante je sais pas si
c'est votre cas ce que
je trouvais modéré dans ses propos il a
rappelé que les président et dirigeant
était démocratiquement il est modéré sur
la pologne est là et la hongrie emmanuel
macron c'est son secrétaire d'état à
l'europe qu'il est moins clémente c'est
en fait oui on va vous rapporter
sinon on va on va on va reprendre
normale et les
également les propos du président donc
il est il est modéré c'est clément bonne
qui est le plus plus modéré plus dur dit
vous sur
les dirigeants hongrois et polonais et
en particulier avec les polémiques qui a
eu soin les sorties de viktor orban ou
bien également la problème le problème
qu'on rencontre avec ce qui se passe en
pologne avec les juges qui sont démis de
leurs fonctions mais cela dit emmanuel
macron est modéré aujourd'hui mais il ne
l'a pas toujours été puisque justement
il avait commencé le lap à la première
partie de son mandat mais celle qui suit
la première partie de son mandat il
avait justement il s'était mis à dos
tous les pays d'europe orientale parce
qu'ils avaient opposé en fait c'était
pendant les élections les dernières
élections européennes
les populismes aux
progressistes est il un torrent vannes
était l'incarnation du voile armes
qu'ils offrent donc réinventer au niveau
européen donc voilà il n'est pas il ya
un problème de il ya un problème de
rapport de force qui n'est pas forcément
emmanuel voix macron voit bien que le
continent est divisé et qu'en plus les
sociétés sont divisés l'extrême droite
en france fait quasiment 50% des voix et
2 et le partage en grande partie les
idées durban et donc on peut pas non
plus complètement maîtrisé cette autre
partie de l'europe qui a aussi une voix
au chapitre
parce qu'elle est dans l'europe pour
l'instant sur les lieux pékin il refuse
de s'aligner sur le boycott diplomatique
dans les amériques un petit message
également sur la grande bretagne j'aime
bien la grande bretagne a une grande
bretagne sans boris johnson le paye
comme ça non c'est moi qui traduit ses
côtés là pour faire un décryptage une
regrette voilà le traduire de l'anglais
qui est prêt il est de plus en plus même
dans le monde diplomatique où c'était
quand même la langue d'usagé était le
français il refuse de reconnaître la fin
du format également normandie c'est à
dire la fin de la présence de la france
et de l'allemagne pour gérer la crise
l'ukraine russie peut-il le ressusciter
ce format qui avait été inauguré par
françois hollande le 6 juin 2004 art
comme le format normandie c'est un peu
comme l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
ce sont deux formats diplomatiques qui
sont morts mais on peut pas le dire est
ce que si on le dit c'est encore pire ya
plus rien et on a peur du vide mais
honnêtement non alors il ya eu une des
idées de en fait de le faire renaître
en amenant les américains dans ce format
normandie pour l'instant ça a pas l'air
de se concrétiser
ça paraît quand même assez mal barré
c'est qu'en fait on va on va sans doute
lui donner un tout petit peu d'air pour
qu'il tienne encore quelques mois mais
mais il restera vide merci beaucoup
isabelle tous ces analyses tous ces
commentaires on les retrouve bien sûr
dans le figaro dans les pages étrangers
dans la verticale internationale sur
lefigaro.fr et puis petites annonces
petit teasing c'est à partir de début
janvier un livre que vous publiez sur la
politique étrangère des manuels macron
on vous attend avec impatience d'abord
pour le lire et ensuite pour venir le
commenter et le présenter aux
internautes du figaro on le disait tout
à l'heure également énormément d'annonce
au plan économique on est revenu
également sur cette question du 3 % on
va y revenir on écoute d'abord le
président de la république sur ces
questions-là deuxième grand axe de cette
présidence française de l'union
européenne
qui je crois d'ailleurs et c'est
dessiner progressivement pour notre pays
comme pour notre continent durant ces
derniers mois et durant cette cette
pandémie que nous avons tous vécu
consiste à bâtir un nouveau modèle
européen de croissance au fond
il nous faut définir ensemble ce que
sera l'europe de 2030
et cette présidence française doit être
l'occasion d'imaginer un nouveau modèle
européen qui est un modèle de production
mais également de solidarité de
régulation en effet notre europe doit
être une europe on puisse produire créer
de la richesse de la richesse est à la
pointe de l'innovation en europe aussi
qu'il doit défendre son modèle social
parce que nous n'avons pas les mêmes
choix collectifs que l'asie ou les états
unis d'amérique et une europe qui doit
être au coeur de l'agenda climatique qui
est aussi qui correspond à nos valeurs
premier pilier c'est évidemment la
capacité à produire à avoir une réponse
économique adapté à la sortie de crise
avec une priorité
faire de l'europe un grand continent de
production d'innovation de création
d'emplois et nous devons partout on
n'aura pas voir une obsession créer des
emplois et lutter contre le chômage et
le chômage de masse tout
particulièrement
bonsoir florentin collomb vous avez été
correspondant à londres vous avez été
également
vous êtes également au journaliste au
figaro économie au service international
et vous étiez sur place cette conférence
de presse l'ambiance en coulisses
l'ambiance était très studieuse à un
grand exposé un grand cours magistral du
président de la république sur ses
intentions pour ses six mois de
présidence européenne des journalistes
très studieux qui n'ont plus beaucoup de
mode et puis une deuxième partie sur des
questions voilà tout à fait normal plus
politique et gagner rappelé politique
des dossiers
le alors certains demandent je fais
juste une réponse par rapport aux
précédentes interventions pourquoi on
appelle le format normandie bien parce
que c'est un format qui avait été trouvé
en marge des commémorations du 6 juin 44
c'était donc le 6 juin 2014
en normandie où avait lieu donc les
cérémonies où il y avait eu une commune
une discussion avec la france
représentée par françois hollande angela
merkel pour l'allemagne viktor
iouchtchenko pour la russie et vladimir
poutine schengen pour l'ukraine et
vladimir poutine pour la russie donc
c'était ce format il y avait également
barack obama je reviens j'en reviens à
vous mon cher florentin peut-être une
question liminaire ce que dit emmanuel
macron vous qui avait couvert le break
site sur sur la grande bretagne
même question pour l'allemagne et pour
que pour la pologne et la hongrie il
avait été l'élément j'ai l'impression
qu'il est quand même dynamique quand
même pas mal au dos dans le thé c'est
vrai qu'il a insisté sur les forces
possibles de rapprochement sur les
facteurs de rapprochement déjà il a fait
la distinction très nette entre le
gouvernement britannique avec lequel on
a du mal à travailler parce qu'il ne
respecte pas sa parole boris johnson
pour ne pas le nommer et les populations
wê tannique et françaises qui on aspire
à travailler ensemble il a aussi
souligné le fait qu'il avait envie
qu'ils aimeraient avoir deux des axes de
coopération avec la grande-bretagne que
c'était difficile en raison des
disputes des différends actuels que ce
soit la pêche les migrations le respect
des accords commerciaux sur le breakbeat
le protocole nord-irlandaise c'est donc
fermeté et volonté de conciliation et si
oui qu'est ce qui nous a frappés dans
cette qu'est ce que vous retenez de
cette de ces deux heures donc oui le
dialogue avec le président il faut bien
comprendre que c'est une grande mise en
scène en réalité d'un très grand nombre
d' un certain nombre de dossiers
économiques et que ces dossiers
économiques et ne tombe pas du ciel tout
d'un coup ce jeudi après-midi et
manuellement acron dévoile ses
propositions pour l'union européenne ce
sont des des dossiers des sujets qui
sont dans les tuyaux depuis le début de
cette commission en fait en 2019 qui
correspondent à la fois aux priorités de
cette commission seul avantage n
essentiellement le climat le
verdissement de l'économie et le
numérique et aux priorités aux visions
de macron sur ce que doit être
l'économie de l'europe c'est à dire une
économie
qui innove qui se réinvente qui produit
donc en fait tout ça est mis ensemble
dans une espèce de grande de grand
exposé des grandes priorités
souveraineté
puissance une europe plus humaine etc
mais en fait c'est le suivi d'un certain
nombre de dossiers qui sont déjà en
cours de négociation avec des grands et
petits c'est pas des petits dossiers
parce que c'est des gros sujets on va
rentrer un petit peu dans les détails
mais c'est des sujets qui existent déjà
qui sont en cours de discussions de
négociations qui ont été présentés par
la commission mais que la france là
pendant ces six mois ou 3 4 mois utiles
à l'intention de faire avancer alors on
va justement a lancé dossier par dossier
il d'ailleurs je précise que vous les
avez dans le chat et dans l'édition
papier du figaro de ce matin où
justement on a listé l'ensemble de ces
dossiers on va regarder propos question
liminaire d'abord est-ce que les
partenaires européens
pourront être séduits comment les
peuvent réagir par rapport justement aux
ambitions qui sont affichés et aux
discours qui a été celui d'emmanuel
maintenant ce soir c'est tout son toute
son ambition à lui de vouloir entraîner
en fait les 27 derrière une vision un
peu collective est ce qu ils peuvent
embarquer on y est déjà la commission
dans des rails on sait ce qu'elle fait
quand elle présente le green deal le
pacte vert les ambitions numérique de
thierry breton pour réguler les gaffes a
cédé choses qui sont déjà sur la table
qui ont déjà fait l'objet pour la
plupart d'une approbation des 27 mais
qui doivent maintenant être négocié avec
le parlement pour devenir des lois des
projets de loi en réalité des directives
des règlements donc il y à vraiment oui
une ambition derrière après il ya des
sujets de fractures aussi comment on va
aborder mais ce qu'il cherche à montrer
et ça c'est peut-être aussi une
dimension politicienne un petit peu la
dent l'occasion de cette conférence de
presse c'est de montrer que l'économie
ce n'est pas que subir de dire on est
dans une dés industrialisation
inéluctable mais qu' on se saisit à bras
le corps de nouveaux dossiers que ce
soit le numérique que ce soit le spatial
que ce soit l'hydrogène le cloud et c
est qu il y a des choses à faire là et
que éventuellement créer des emplois
comme ça c'est ça c'est l'image qu'il
veut montrer par rapport à ses
compétiteurs pour la est-ce que ça peut
s'exercer artistes européens mais ils
sont dedans est tout le monde et soumet
le loger derrière cette même logique oui
les sujets qui fâchent bien entendu
c'est pas pour c'est le budget voilà et
ça alors on rappelle un pur parce que
les critères de ma portion ceux qui
n'ont pourrait ceux qui n'ont pas eu le
plaisir de notre 21e
grand talent et 3 % se sont l'engagement
compris que ont pris les pays européens
est ratifié par le traité de maastricht
1992 de ne pas dépasser dans son budget
chaque année 3% de déficit pour cent de
pib en déficit et 60 % d'endettement est
aujourd'hui l'union européenne est en
moyenne à 100% d'endettement du pib la
france presque 120 % l'état 860 donc
tout ça a complètement explosé donc là
on dépasse on dépasse assez
régulièrement le trail et 3% très
régulièrement pendant des années et là
on était à 8 9% pour la crise on va
descendre à 5% l'année prochaine les
règles ont été suspendues depuis le
début de la pandémie 2020 21 22 à partir
de 2023 soit elle serait appliquée soit
il faudra les avoir réformé il ya déjà
une
processus en cours pour les réformés qui
a été lancée par la commission macron
lui-même en 2019 avant la pandémie avait
dit que c'était des règles d'un autre
siècle ce soir il l'a redit l'a dit ce
sont d'énormes dépasser ce sont des
tabous des fétiches sur lesquels il est
vain de se disputer donc là où c'était
intéressant la façon dont il a présenté
les choses aujourd'hui c'est qu'il
montre clairement la volonté de la
france de se saisir de ce sujet qui
fâche ce sujet explosif en réalité
puisque les vingt-sept sont loin d'être
d'accord là dessus et on pensait que la
france allait peut-être laissé passer ça
au second plan que des négociations
auraient lieu mais que la france ne se
saisirait pas du tout du sujet la patate
chaude est en réalité non seulement ils
s'en emparent mais il organise même un
sommet des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement en france au mois de mars
les 10 et 11 mars je crois sur ce thème
précisément donc en gros il veut les
mettre dans une salle comme ce qui avait
été fait en plein coeur de la pandémie
en juillet 2020 pour que personne ne
sorte de ce sommet jusqu'à ce qu'ils se
mettent d'accord sur le fond de relance
il veut profiter de ce de créer ce genre
de nouveaux momentum d'une dynamique
entre en le saisissant haut niveau chefs
d'état chefs de gouvernement pas
uniquement ministre des finances pour
les mettre autour de la table et dire ça
ne peut plus durer il faut qu'on
réfléchisse à un nouveau cadre
simplifiée plus modernes ou n'est pas
forcément question d'un chiffre abstrait
de 3% de déficit mais de ce qu'il dit
quels sont les investissements qu'on
veut faire dans la défense dans le
climat dans le numérique de combien
d'argent on a besoin combien on va
mettre sur la table quel budget on veut
en commun ou bien qu'est-ce qu'on veut
laisser aux états comme marge de
manoeuvre est pour derrière ces chiffres
abstraits nantes 1 c'est là aussi encore
c'était le président âge de gens qui
sont nés au 20e siècle c'est que il y
avait c'était quelqu'un points qui
visait à rassurer un pays qui est l
allemagne c'est à dire 3 % c'était on
assuré qu on faisait une rig on avait
une rigueur dans la gestion il qu'on
ferait pas n'importe quoi dans l'est
dans les dépenses est ce que aujourd'hui
l'allemagne qui est tous les cas et
qu'ils attachent un fort attachement qui
a un fort attachement justement à la
rigueur de gestion tout comme des pays
d'europe du nord pour certains
fondateurs de l'union européenne je
pense notamment aux pays bas peuvent
accepter de changer ce logiciel de
passer de d'un logiciel justement de
d'investissement investissement a plutôt
un logiciel de gestion de way tableur
excel oui c'est c'est le pari que fait
la france
que fait clairement macron que fait même
bruno le maire alors qu'il était
beaucoup plus réservé parce qu'il
voulait préserver aussi la réputation de
une certaine réputation de bonne gestion
de la france de se dire que la donne a
changé à berlin que la donne a changé à
l'issue de là
pandémie et qu'il a dit cet après midi
on ne peut pas revenir on ne peut pas
faire comme si rien ne s'était passé et
de montrer qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
défis à la hauteur des européens si on
veut s'en saisir si on veut investir
pour être à la hauteur pour pour
construire une économie du 21e siècle
une économie des années 2030 et au delà
il faut s'en donner les moyens donc il
l'aimé un peu au pied du mur en dix ans
soit on continue à gérer comme de bon
père de famille ce que la france ne
faisait pas c'est vrai soit on décide
quelles sont les grandes priorités
d'investissement et on voit si on sort
ses investissements du cadre budgétaire
traditionnels contraint par ses limites
de dépenses ou on prolonge le grand
fonds d'investissement mutualisé qui a
été mis au point pendant la pandémie
entre emmanuel macron et angela merkel
puis les 27 derrière ça n'a pas été
facile de les embarquer mais enfin c'est
quand même merkel et macron qui se sont
mis d'accord là dessus et du coup ils
ouvrent ce débat qui est un débat
compliqué où il ya beaucoup de coups à
prendre
mais il à l'envi de le mettre sur la
table et là encore il ya aussi une
arrière pensée électorale c'est qu'en
face et se fait accuser par certains
candidats ou candidates d'avoir cramer
la caisse et là il va leur démontrer une
valérie pécresse voilà il veut lord il
veut essayer de leur démontrer que si on
veut investir dans une économie du futur
il faut dépenser des millions de l'idée
c'est ouais c'était le quoi qu'il en
coûte pendant la crise et maintenant
c'est l'idée d'investir pour rénover
relancer l'économie donc la relance est
au coeur de cette présidence française
un autre point peut-être est-ce que
c'est un sujet qui fâche mais il a
relancer ou en tout cas
reparler et défendu l'idée d'une taxe
carbone aux frontières c'est aussi un
sujet qui fâche et aussi avec
l'allemagne c'est comme une mesure
protectionniste ses bas c'est une mesure
qui vise à mettre en adéquation là on
adéquation les efforts climatiques pour
verdir l'économie qu'on fait en europe
avec le reste du monde parce que la
logique c'est de se dire si nous on met
des contraintes sur nos entreprises pour
qu'elles produisent plus vers
sa ping écologique il y aura un dumping
total si on achète des produits en chine
outils des industriels français se
mettent à délocaliser ailleurs pour ne
pas pour échapper à ces conditions donc
l'idée c'est se dire ce que les autres
ne font pas pour verdir leurs économies
et bien on va le taxer à l'entrée c'est
un sujet qui est en effet considérée
comme protectionniste par l'allemagne un
petit peu la france était très seule
quand elle a commencé à proposer ce
sujet est aujourd'hui ça avance ça fait
partie du paquet vert que la commission
a présenté l'été dernier c'est pas gagné
et ça c'est très probable qu'il
n'obtiendra pas gain de cause d'ici la
fin de la présidence de l'union
européenne parce que c'est trop court
les délais sont trop courts pour se
mettre d'accord là dessus l'allemagne
compte par principe par jallet idéologie
ou l excellent et où elle est contre
parce que elle même à quelques problèmes
avec le carbone en lavant problème avec
le carbone
l'allemagne ne veut pas se mettre des
bâtons dans les roues en termes de
commerce extérieur puisque l'allemagne
est beaucoup plus exportatrice est
beaucoup plus en été par les âges et la
chine en particulier avec la chine et du
coup elle ne peut pas mettre ça en péril
mais elle a dit que si c'était dans le
cadre de l'om sait que ça ne ne venait
pas à l'encontre des règles de l'om
s'est elle approuverait le mc pourrait
accepter oui bah il faut voir il faut
voir exactement ce qui va être discuté
parce que le diable est dans les détails
c'est une protéine une mesure très très
complexe m à mettre quoi faire de
l'europe une puissance du numérique
c'est encore là une belle idée il est
creuse ou bien à ce qu'il y à vraiment
faire une idée en creux on va dire parce
que l'europe n'est pas une puissance du
numérique tous les géants dont on parle
en permanence ils sont américains pour
l'essentiel chinois aussi
donc faute d'avoir ces géants alors on
veut certes en créant les poires émerger
et peut-être que dans des futurs
domaines comme l'intelligence
artificielle etc on aura des européens
mais en attendant la démarche actuelle
c'est de réguler les géants américains
par des textes assez ambitieux qui vise
à mettre un cadre très strict à leurs
activités en europe une europe qui
créent des emplois pas de déflation
parce que ça crée la guerre lasse et une
déclaration pour les autres partenaires
européens où c'est plutôt pour le
référencement vibrante et la déflation
je pensais comme on
parle comme le plaidoyer pour la
politique fiscale du gouvernement qui si
on en croit et mener le mâcon à stopper
le déclin industriel
vous dites quand même pardon est ce que
quand emmanuel macron dit qu' il faut
relancer une grande politique
industrielle à l'échelle de l'europe
est-ce que là encore les autres pays
européens sont d'accord il ya des
projets en cours il ya des projets avec
l'allemagne avec l'italie avec l'espagne
sur les batteries notamment sur le
spatial sur le cloud sur l'hydrogène ou
beaucoup de paix plusieurs pays
européens y compris l'espagne veulent
participer donc l'idée c'est d'étendre
ses s'est pour l'instant ce sont des
projets de coopération entre plusieurs
pays vit des salaires du salariat
est ce qu'on n'a pas vécu quand même ce
soir a également un peu un tournant
dans le discours en tout cas le sait le
refus de tout sacrifier sur l'autel de
la consommation est en tout cas du
consommateur européen mais c'est une
redéfinition de ce qu'est l'europe parce
que l'europe était a été conçu comme un
marché un grand marché de 450 millions
de citoyens et consommateurs division
britannique c'était la division
britannique c'était la vision libérale
qui ont partagé à peu près aussi c'était
et les règles de concurrence européennes
visait à préserver tous les facteurs de
ce marché que la concurrence soit libre
entre les entreprises et
macron revendique une vision différente
où ce n'est pas que le marché et les
consommateurs mais aussi une politique
industrielle la constitution de
champions quitte à les aider avec des
fonds publics c'est un peu toute la
démarche qui était exposé ce soir pour
pour stimuler
pour stimuler cette politique
industrielle et d'ailleurs il s'inspire
aussi de ce que fait joe biden aux états
unis et joe biden déverse et énormément
d'argent dans un plan pour développer
les infrastructures etc et soutenir
aussi des champions nationaux donc il se
dit il l'a dit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
si la chine et les etats unis
investissent mille ou cent il est hors
de question que l'europe investisse 10
au même moment la banque centrale
européenne la hausse y suivra cette fois
ci la banque centrale européenne est un
peu un tournant parce qu'elle a déployé
énormément de moyens pour
soutenir les états dans la pandémie
aujourd'hui on est face à un problème
d'inflation je ne sais pas si on peut
dire galopante mais en tout cas
inquiétante
et il le faut aussi veiller à juguler ce
problème donc la bce est un peu prise en
étau entre les deux qui était là session
originel de la bc oui c'est sa mise en
pression des allemands et c'est toujours
sa mission et c'est la mission de toutes
les banques centrales de veiller à la
stabilité des prix et la stabilité des
prix on n'y est pas il a reconnu en
creux quand on a pas d'entreprise pour
produire les vaccins il y l'europe c'est
la solution on a l'impression que
finalement les coûts tant au plan
économique l'europe c'est là pour
colmater un peu les branches de
l'économie française
c'est pour montrer que tout seul on est
trop petit et trop isolé et qu'on n'a
pas tous les moyens donc c'est vrai
qu'au début de la campagne de
vaccination début de cette année boris
johnson s'est targué d'avoir pu mener sa
campagne de vaccination grâce au brésil
ce qui n'était pas vraiment le cas parce
que même s'ils étaient dans l'union
européenne il aurait pu faire la même
chose mais surtout grâce au vaccin
astrazeneca qui avait été mis au point
par le laboratoire d'oxford dont qu'ils
avaient ce vaccin nationale à oxford
astrazeneca laboratoire qui a un pied en
grande bretagne
nous on n'a pas pu ans le vaccin sanofi
on l'attend toujours donc ma cran dit
que si on est à l'échelle européenne
on aurait juste envoyer nos bons de
commande à pfizer
le vaccin mis au point par les allemands
en attendant qu'ils veuillent bien nous
le livrer donc c'est vrai que et ça
c'est un argument qui combat entendent
beaucoup pendant la campagne je pense